ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE TO. ORDER.
WE ARE CLOSE TO GETTING A QUORUM
I JUST NEED ONE MORE PERSON TO
SHOW UP- AND THERE WOULD LIKE
SOME AUTHORS- MISTER CHANG MISS
CARRILLO. I MISS RUBIO MISTER
RIVAS AND MYSELF I THANK IN THE
NAME OF THE AUTHORS OTHER
AUTHORS SHOW UP I'M GOING TO DO
MY BILL. WE CAN STARTED TO SUB
COMMITTEE. AND I WILL TURN OVER
THE GAVEL TO MISTER SMITH.
HERE'S YOUR CHANCE TO GO THROUGH
ALL THAT STUFF- WELL WE HAVEN'T
GOT A QUORUM YET- I SHOULD SAY
IN THE. THE- YEAH ALL THE HOUSE
KEEP STAFF I DO THAT FIRST. OF
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE HEARING. THIS CAN BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO HAVE THE
OPTION OF TESTIFYING VIA. PHONE
LINE. THE CALL IN NUMBERS FOR
THIS HEARING ARE ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR SCREEN. THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
I'LL REPEAT THAT. IT IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE.
FOUR FOUR FOUR. SO THAT'S ACCESS
CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE NOTE THAT
CALL IN TESTIMONY WILL BE
COMBINED FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND WILL BE TAKEN
AFTER BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. I MERRY WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED PRIMARY WITNESS
TESTIMONY OUR MONEY IS LIMITED
TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
SIDE. ALSO PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT IF YOU ARE A PRIMARY
WITNESS COLLEEN AND- YOU WILL
REMAIN A LIFELINE AND WILL LEAD
TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO STATING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF THEY REPRESENT
ON. THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL-
I ALSO WANNA NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA- WELL EVENTUALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE WALDRON
WILL JOIN THE COMMITTEE WHEN SHE
COMES IN ALL INTRODUCER. WE HAVE
ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
FOR WHICH RIDE CONSENT- WE NEED
ONE MORE PERSON TO MAKE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND THERE BE NO
OTHER AUTHORS. I'M GOING TO
PRESENT MY BILL.
SEVEN I DON'T THINK YES YEAH I.
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT SOME OF THE
- THANK RIGHT WE DON'T PARK YEAH
THANK.
WELL MISTER KIRK PLEASE PRESS
YOUR BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS. ARE BRING
TODAY A C. EIGHTY. WHICH UPDATE
THE PAST POURS PREVENT PRO- WE
IS ALSO A CO THE MAN TO PROGRAM
. THIS PROGRAM REQUIRE THAT A
HAVE WERE WHO WHAT'S TOXIC
PASSED. HAVE THEIR WORK MONITOR
BY FOR TO PREVENT FROM BEING
OVER EXPOSED TO POINT AND ON THE
JOB. MY BILL DOES TWO THINGS HIS
EXTENSIVE SUNSET ON THE
REQUIREMENT FOR LABORATORIES.
TRANSMIT PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
DATED TO THE APARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. OR DPR AND
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WORKERS
PHYSICIANS ARE REGISTERED AS
PART OF THE PROGRAM. AND IT
REQUIRES LABORATORIES TO
TRANSMIT A FEW MORE PIECES OF
IDENTIFYING DATA TO. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. BOTH OF THESE
PROVISIONS WILL BETTER ENABLE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE RELATED
. PESTICIDE REGULATION TO
IDENTIFY TRACK AND PROTECT
WORKERS HANDLING DANGEROUS
PESTICIDES SO WHAT HAPPENS ON
THIS ARE. YOU COULD CALL FOR A
QUORUM I BELIEVE WE GOT- WE LOST
SOMEBODY ALL RIGHT. ONE MAR YEAH
WE LOST OUR BARBY K. OKAY. YES
THANK YOU- SO WHAT THE REASON
WHY WE NEED THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS WE'RE NOT LOOKING
FOR A PARTICULAR SINGLE LEVEL OF
CHEMICAL THAT THEY'RE FIGHTING
IN THE BLOOD WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR IS A CHANGE IN- THE
NEUROCHEMICAL OVERTIME. AND THAT
MEANS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO TELL WHEN SOMEONE IS CHANGING
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT AN ABSOLUTE
LEVEL IS AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SO WE CAN
TRACK THINGS OVER TIME. WELL
WITH ME TODAY. IS- LISA.
GONZALEZ FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION AND ON THE
PHONE WE HAVE DOCTOR DR MARGARET
REEVES THE SENIOR SCIENTIST FROM
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK NORTH
AMERICA- COULD SOMEONE BRING THE
TIMER. TO THE VICE CHAIR- OF SO
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO TESTIFY FOR
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES- CHOSE HIM
AS TWO MINUTES EACH AND LESS
IT'S DIFFERENT WHICH CASE LET ME
OUT SO GO AHEAD- THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FORTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ. AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATION AND POLICY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION THE DEPARTMENT AS A
SPONSOR OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP
IMPROVE THE DATA QUALITY OF THE
STATE RECEIVES UNDER THE MEDICAL
SUPERVISION PROGRAM AND EXTENDS
A SUNSET OF THE PROGRAM. THE
DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE OVERALL ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM AND THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION OF
MEDICAL SUPERVISORS IN JANUARY
THE DEPARTMENT AND- WE HAVE
PROVIDED AN UPDATE TO THE
LEGISLATURE ANALYZING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM AND
THE USEFULNESS OF CURRENT
REPORTING. THE UPDATE FOUND THAT
THE PROGRAM APPEARS EFFECTIVE
BUT THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO
RECEIVE TEST RESULTS WITH
MISSING AND INCOMPLETE DATA
IMPACTING OUR ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM. BY
REQUIRING LABORATORIES TO SHARE
MORE DATA WITH THE DEPARTMENT
THE STATE WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION CONTACT THE
NECESSARY OUTREACH FOLLOW UP IN
TRAINING TO BETTER PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH IN MOST CASES THE
LABORATORIES PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES SOME OF THE
INFORMATION REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS PRACTICE EXPANDED. AND
STANDARDIZED. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THE DEPARTMENT ALREADY HAS
IN PLACE A CURRENT- SECURE
SYSTEM FOR STORING THIS DATA AND
STRICT PROTOCOLS FOR WHO CAN
ACCESS THIS DATA. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR NOW WE CAN
ESTABLISH CORE YEP EXACTLY WHAT
I'M GONNA DO IS MADAM SECRETARY
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM IS TAKE ROLE
BEFORE ANYBODY DECIDES TO LEAVE
. TO STOP WAS QUORUM CORK. CORK
HERE SMITH HERE SMITH HERE
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN. POWER CAN
HERE CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA HERE HOLDEN. MATHIS
MATHIS HERE WHAT TOO CHEAP.
WALDRON WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HAVE THE SET UP OF FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WE DO HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS ON THE PHONE LINE. AND
PHONE MODERATOR CAN YOU PLACE DR
MARGARET RIVAS SENIOR SCIENTIST
FOR PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK
NORTH AMERICA ON THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE. I CAN REACH. HELLO AND
PHONE OPERATOR OR DO WE HAVE
DOCTOR MARGARET RIVAS YES DR
MARGARET READ OKAY GOT AND GIVE
US YOUR PRESENTATION. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU CHAIRED
BY STERN COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY BY NAME SHE'S
ALWAYS MARK DR MARGARET REEVES
HERE SORRY OF PACIFIC ACTION
WHERE ARE YOU WERE FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. OF THE
PROPOSAL IS TO BETTER PROTECT
FARMWORKERS FROM EXPOSURE TO
AGRICULTURAL PESTICIDES. KERN
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS AND IS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE STATEWIDE
COALITION CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND WE HAVE
SUPPORTED SEVERAL BILL
SUPPORTING THIS PROGRAM SB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY SB TWENTY NINE NINETY
TWO. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SB
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND TWENTY
TEN SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN- OF HAVE
ALREADY BEEN JUST. OF MEDICAL
SUPPLY FOR WITH BLOOD TESTS. A
NERVOUS AND ON CALL STORAGE FOR.
WHO MAKES. AND APPLIED TALK
ORDER FONG AND END OF THE CALL.
PURPOSE SO THE BILL NOT PUT ME.
INFORMATION BEFORE BUT ALSO THE
REQUIRED FOR LOAN TO WITH IN. A
POSITION TO REPORT JUST A WITH A
WITHOUT. TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
SEVEN. BECAUSE THESE THE FIVE
ARE STILL BEING USED. CAL WITH
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION COME
USING TWENTY. FOR THE PAST FIVE
MIXER IN APPLICATORS WELCOME TO
BE PROTECTED. I AM ALSO GOING TO
SCHOOL. ALSO FOR THE DEATH AND
SO WE AND DEEP. CAN ACCRUE
COMPLY PROVIDE NEEDED TRAINING
FOR THE PRO. POSITION AND DO SO
ACCURATELY WE'RE IN- THAT
CLEARLY JUST.
SECOND THANK YOU MISTER REEVES
AT THIS TIME WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT IS GOING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SEEING
NONE DO WE HAVE ONE ANYONE IT-
OKAY NO GET. HI MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS- MY NAME IS MUST AGAIN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN THE PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE
WAITING OUTSIDE TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT. OKAY WILL ASK OF ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WHO
WILL GIVE A COUPLE MINUTES SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
HALLWAY. THE NEW FOR MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ONE ON A PHONE LINE.
IN SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION BUT-
WE DO HAVE ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. GO AHEAD PUT
AMONG LINE. AT NINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE FOR MODERATOR. WHO
SAID ONE OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FROM
A COMMITMENT MEMBERS. HEY I DO
BELIEVE WE HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND. HOME ON THE BACK TO THE
CLOSER. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
YOU RUN A GOOD MEETING. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL
RECALL. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CORK THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORK ALL RIGHT
QUIRK I SMITH HI SMITH HI
ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN OUR QUE
HAN I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN MATHIS. MATHIS I
WANTED TO G. WALDRON WE HAVE
FIVE VOTES WITHOUT. THANK. OKAY-
YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT WORK BETTER
FOR. THREE HUNDRED- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY WE
HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY THREE CORK ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE YES TÌM
ITEM ELEVEN. MADE AT LEAST THREE
BILLS ARE- ON CONSENT AND THERE
DO PASSED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER TEN ALSO
CONSENT ITEM THAT HAS THE MOTION
TO PASS TO THE FLOOR ON CONSENT
SO WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON ALL
FOUR CONSENT CALENDAR QUIRK. ALL
RIGHT HI SMITH SMITH HI ARAMBULA
. OUR QUE HAN. ERA CAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA
HI HOLDEN MATHIS MATHIS I WOULD
HAVE TO G. WALDRON. SO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FIVE VOTES
THAT'S OUT. FOR GOOD. THANK YOU-
I BELIEVE THE ONLY OFFERED THE
ROOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO WHO HASN'T ACTUALLY BILL
2% TO LESS. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY THREE WHICH IS REALLY
MYFIRST PRESENTATION OF THE
YEARS THANK YOU ARE WHICH
EXTENDS THE REPEAL DATE FOR THE
YOU PROVIDE OUR BASE AND WATER
QUALITY OF THIRTY OR WE CALL THE
I. W. Q. WAY TO JULY OF TWENTY
FIFTY THE COMPLEX WATERSHEDS OF
THE THANK YOU PROVIDE VALUE
MOUNTAINS PROVIDES WATER FOR
NEARLY NEARLY A MILLION
RESIDENTS OF THE THANK YOU FOR
VALLEY AND TO SPECIFICALLY TO MY
DISTRICT UNFORTUNATELY THE WATER
QUALITY OF THE BASIN IS CAUGHT
COMPLICATED- BY DECADES OF POOR
ENVIRONMENTAL OVERSIGHT DURING
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY. WE HAVE
ORGANIC COMPOUNDS P. FIVE AND
NUMEROUS OTHER VOLATILE
CONTAMINATIONS- THAT PLAGUE OUR
WATER SYSTEM AND ITS TEAM THE
BASED AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
LARGEST SUPERFUND SITES IN THE
WHOLE ENTIRE COUNTRY ON THE TASK
OF ORGANIZING A PROVIDING
FUNDING TO THE REMEDY THE CLEAN
UP- AND THE CLEAN UP OF THE
BASIN WAS DELEGATED TO THE
CENTRAL. MASON WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY. BY AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO. THE W. Q. A HAS OVERSEEN
NEARLY HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
AND RICK WE MEET RE MEDIATION
EFFORTS ACCOUNTING FOR NEARLY.
50% OF THE TOTAL CONTAMINANTS
REMOVED FROM THE BASIN.
UNFORTUNATELY AS THE COMMITTEE
IS ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH THE
EFFORTS TO REMEDIATE GROUNDWATER
POLLUTION- THIS IS OUR LAW.
THESE ARE ALL LONG TERM AND
COMPLICATED- COMPLETE
COMPLICATED BY NEWLY EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS. AS SUCH THE W. Q.
AS MISSION HAS BEEN EXTENDED
SEVERAL TIMES MOST RECENTLY IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE LONG TERM PLANNING AND
CONTRACTING. TO MEET WATER
QUALITY GOALS AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THREE EXTENDS THE REPEAL
DATE. OF THE W. Q. EIGHT TO JULY
OF TWENTY FIFTY. THE WORK DONE
BY THE WPA IS INVALUABLE TO MY
DISTRICT AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BASIN WATER QUALITY- AUTHORITY
HAS SET THE STANDARD FOR EFFORTS
IN THIS SPACE AND I WANT TO ADD
THAT IT'S- UP FOR MY DISTRICT
BUT IT ALSO STEP TO STOP THE
CUTS. THAT CONTAMINATION GOING
INTO THE LA BASIN SO IT'S-
IMPORTANT FOR MY DISTRICT BY THE. FOR THE WHOLE LA BASIN AS
WELL. HERE TODAY WITH IS RANDY
SHOULDER MEANT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE TANGIBLE VALUE
BOB MASON WATER QUALITY AT THE
READY- A FEW OF. I THINK HE'S ON
THE PHONE SO. THANK YOU OKAY.
SHOW OF EIGHTEEN ANTI COULD YOU
GET TO. OUR WITNESS ON THE PHONE
RANDY CHARLEMAINE. I'M HERE.
OKAY GO AHEAD HI MY NAME- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M RANDY SOLOMON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE THING
IT WILL BE SO FAR QUALITY OF
FORTY- THE AUTHORITY WAS CREATED
NINETEEN NINETY TWO TO FILL A
NEED IN THE THANK YOU FOR VALLEY
AND THAT WAS. A DEDICATED LOCAL
AGENCY TO MANAGE AND FACILITATE
CLEANUP OF CONTAMINANTS. IN THE
MAIN BATHROOM WHICH PROVIDES
NINETY PERCENT. OF THE DRINKING
WATER FOR OVER MILLION PEOPLE
PRESIDENT. WE ARE GOVERNED BY A
SEVEN MEMBER BOARD MADE UP OF
WATER PURVEYORS. CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS WHICH
PROVIDES. A BROAD REPRESENTATION
. OUR AGENCY PARTNERS WITH ARE
YOU TO AGENCY PARTNERS INCLUDE
THE U. S. EPA THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL ORDER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD AND THE STATE BOARD AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. IT
COLLABORATED WITH THESE AGENCIES
TO INVESTIGATE SITES AND THE
PLANNING CONSTRUCT THREE
METHODOLOGIES. OVER THE PAST-
SEVERAL DECADES. THE WATER
QUALITY THIRTY HAS- HAS THE
THING GIVE A BASIN GROUNDWATER
QUALITY MANAGEMENT REMEDIATION
PLAN. I THAT WE UPDATE EVERY
YEAR IT PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE
VIEW OF THE MEDIATION EFFORTS
AND THE ENTIRE BASEMENT. OUR
WORKALSO INCLUDES ENGAGING WITH
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES WHICH HAS
LED TO SUBSTANTIAL SETTLEMENTS
AND LONG TERM FUNDING AGREEMENTS
FOR THE CLEAN UP. HE FURTHER
OFFSET THE COST TO CLEAN UP THE-
IN THE RAPE AND TO THE REPAIRS
THE WATER QUALITY THREE PROVIDES
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS BY
ACCESSING BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FROM GRANTS. THE THIRTY
ALSO HAVE THE FEDERAL
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE THING
APRIL BATES AND RESTORATION FUND
. THE W. IS ESTABLISHED A GOOD
REPRESENTATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND PROVIDE THAT
REACHED. INFORM THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT OUR WORK. WE HAVE BEEN
EXTENDED SEVERAL TIMES.
PREVIOUSLY DUE TO THE VALUE IN
SERVICE WE BRING TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE COMMUNITY.
OUR MANAGEMENT OF THE CLEANUP
INVOLVED LONG TERM PROJECT
AGREEMENT AND THE NEED TO
ADDRESS FUTURE EMERGING CAN.
THEREFORE REQUEST AN EXTENSION
OF A REPEAL DATES JULY FIRST TO
TWENTY FIFTY TO CONTINUE OUR
IMPORTANT WORK. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU AND YOU DID IT PERFECTLY TWO
MINUTES I LIKE IT- SO NOW WE CAN
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SIGNON IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OKAY THEN
WE'LL GO TO EIGHTEEN T. AND
ANYONE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSED TO AB TWO ONE SIX THREE.
H. TWO ONE SIX THREE ONLY PLEASE
GIVE ME YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION THANK YOU. AND
WE GO TO ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF ANNA
CARBAJAL ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN MEXICO
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MOVING ON THE LINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST INTO A MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO VALUE TO
STILL WATER DISTRICT AT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU. OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. NONE- WELL. I GUESS
IT'S TIME TO ASK YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT AND
I'D LIKE TO SAY THIS IS JUST SO
IMPORTANT AND I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE
BRINGING IT FORWARD. I USED TO
LIVE IN THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
AND- HI I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. TO THE PEOPLE OF SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY SO THANK YOU AGAIN. MADAM
SECRETARY. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE
BLANCA RUBIO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
BY CORK I SMITH. ARAMBULA BAUER
K. HAND HOW CAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN
. MATHIS MATHIS I WANTED TO G.
WALDRON. OKAY WE HAVE FOUR VOTES
HE THAT ON CALL. OKAY THANK VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- CARRILLO-
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SO THIS
BILL CLARIFIES THE CONSUMER
PRODUCTS EXEMPTION FROM THE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS BUSINESS
PLAN PROGRAM THIS DAMAGE IS
ELECTRONIC RECORD REQUIREMENTS
FOR SUPPLIERS OF HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS. SO PLEASE PROCEED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIFTY NINE WHICH REQUIRES
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPLY AND MOVE
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL TO RETAIN
SALES SHIPPING AND TRANSFER
INFORMATION AND TO MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO LOCAL CERTIFIED
UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCIES
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS COOPER US. TO
IDENTIFY LARGE QUANTITIES OF
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN PROPERLY REPORTED TO
THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITIES THIS
BILL WILL ALSO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
BY NARROWING THE QUALIFICATIONS
FOR A RETAIL EXEMPTION AN
EXEMPTION THAT HAS ALLOWED BAD
ACTORS TO STORE LARGE QUANTITIES
OF HIGHLY FLAMMABLE MATERIALS
AWAY FROM CALIFORNIA'S.
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL LAWS
THIS CHANGE WILL STILL ONLY
REQUIRE INFORMATION TO BE
REPORTED FOR AMOUNTS OVER THE
THREE TIMES THE CURRENT
AFFORDABLE LEVELS OUTSIDE OF
THIS EXEMPTION ON MAY SIXTEENTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY A FIRE AT A
BUILD A FIRE STARTED A BUILDING
ON VOIGTS STREET IN DOWNTOWN LA.
THAT FIRE CAUSED A LARGE
EXPLOSION BECAUSE OF A
COLLECTION OF BUTANE GAS PRESENT
A COLLECTION THAT WASN'T
DISCLOSED IN THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL REPORTING SYSTEM
AS A RESULT OF THAT VERY LARGE
AND VERY SUDDEN FIRE ELEVEN LOS
ANGELES CITY FIREFIGHTERS WERE
INJURED. UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT
THE ONLY EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENING CALIFORNIA
COOPER'S ON THE FRONT LINES OF
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS SAFE BY
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE'S
PROTECTIONS FROM HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS AND WASTE ARE ADHERED
TO HOWEVER IN THIS INSTANCE.
THERE IS A DEFICIENCY AND
CURRENT LAW AND WE NEED TO GIVE
OUR COOPER HAS MORE TOOLS TO
WORK WITH SO THAT THEY CAN
UNCOVER BUSINESSES THAT ARE
WILLFULLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIREMENTS REPORT HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS AND MATERIAL STORED ON
SITE. THE BILL IS COMMONSENSE
NARROWLY TAILORED SOLUTION THAT
IS INTENDED TO TARGET BAD ACTORS
AND WITHOUT CREATING ADDITIONAL
COMPLICATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE AND SUPPORT OUR
TO INDIVIDUALS WITH PROFESSIONAL
KNOWLEDGE ON THIS TOPIC- ROYCE
LONG CUBA PROGRAM COORDINATOR
FOR THE LOS ANGELES CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE- BEFORE. BORN FOR- FORM
BOREDOM SORRY. AN FRICTION PAST
CHAIR OF THE COOPER FORUM AS
WELL AS THE ASSISTANT FIRE
MARSHAL AND COOPER MANAGER WITH
THE SANTA CLARA FIRE DEPARTMENT.
VERY GOOD AND JUST SO WE CAN NOW
HEAR FROM MISTER ROGERS LONG
JUST YOU CAN START BUT PLEASE
EXPLAIN WHAT A COOPER IS AND
WHAT TO PERFORM BOARD HAS I'LL
GIVE YOU AN EXTRA TWENTY SECONDS
TO DO PATH. HE HAD A PROBLEM.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CORECONNECT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF A COOPER IS THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY
AND NOT SHALL. WE ARE REGULATED-
GOVERNMENT- PROGRAM AND JOB IS
TO- BEFORE DEPARTMENTAL
REGULATIONS AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC AND ALSO
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THE COUPON
BOARDS REPRESENT- THAT COULD
COST OF BY THIS ACTUALLY COULD
BE ASSEMBLY CORPORATIST BY THE
AGENCY. IN A TOTAL OF THE
HUNDRED FIVE DAYS AGENCIES BYE
BYE. THAT MISSION IS TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. THANK YOU GOD. THE UP
THANK YOU SO. BUT MEMBER CREA AT
GOT THE BOLSTER EXPOSURE WELHAM
FIVE IT WOULD BE GREAT BURN CHU
EFFORT MET THE HAVE HAD THE DATA
FROM THE BEACH THANK THE PIPES
AND LOCATE WITH FEW THINGS I
THINK CALLED WITHIN THE- AND
THEN WHAT THE GAS ANOTHER IN THE
A LOT SIXTH TWO THOUSAND ONE- I
THREE CANNOT BUILDING FIRE. I LA
P. PROHIBIT THE BUT PICKING
THROUGH THE ROLL. AND UPON THIS
. LEADING TO A BASEMENT UPON
ENTRY THE BASE BUT THE IMPACT
FOUND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND POUND-
BUT SOME OF GATE. FOR THE DATA
ON THE CREEK UPON. EXPLODE PAUL
WAS. A MERE DATA SAID BILLING
THAT ACTIVE CHAU CARE. ASSEMBLY
WAS NOT BREAKING LAW FROM TO
VOTE TO BE. AS IT IS FOR. BY THE
REACH THANK UNDER AND SAY CODE.
BUT THE TAKE EFFECT. BENEFIT YOU
VERY A SMALL TO PROTECT THE-
STATE'S RETALLICK WAS BE IN. TO
EXCLUDE. QUANTITY OF HIGH RISK A
PUTS. BOB FIGURE IN THE PAINT
THOSE HIGH TO MY AND- MANY LIVES
BUT BUILT. ACROSS THE BY THE
MENU. CENTER- THE PLANT IS WAY
AND- WITHOUT ANY SAID PAYMENT
HAS MATERIAL. YEAH A LOT ANGELES
BUT APART AND THEY ALEX DECRYPT
DE MANY THE ABOUT BY DURING THIS
TIME. ONE SUCH INCIDENT ALEX THE
ORDER LEGAL. OF THE FIGHT MANY
MONTH LATER THE L. A. WAS NOT BY
FAN BUT BE AN EXTRA. THAT THEY
HAD HUNDREDS OF SENATE HOW THE
PILOT ABANDONED IN THE FIELD
DURING THE BRAIN MAY AS THE
OPERATION AT LEAST. MANY THE
KIND OF TIME BUSINESS. WHEN BY
THE COOPER SB PICK UP THERE ARE.
AND MOVE TO ANOTHER LOCATION.
REALLY THAT THE UNTIL THERE'S
ANOTHER FIVE OR EXPLOSION. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE THE BE ATARI
REQUIRE ON THE OF ALL. TO
DISCLOSE THE INTENDED AS AT TEN.
OF THE BUT- FOR THE PROTECTION
OF IT. AND AFTER THREE AS WE
RESPECT REQUEST SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AT THE YOU
MISTER LARA. AND DEBT NOW. WE
CAN HEAR FROM MR- JOHN. GO AHEAD
FRED AFTER GAME. A GOOD
AFTERNOON YOU CHAIR QUIRK AND
PHONE OF THE IF TIM COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU ALL MY NAME IS
FREDERICK CHUN I AM THE
ASSISTANT FIRE MARSHAL COOPER
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR BAY AREA
CITY. J. I'M TESTIFYING ON TO
THE SCREEN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COULD PERFORM OR AND
THIS OUT THIS PAST YEAR.
CURRENTLY THERE ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND BUSINESSES
SUBJECT TO THE HOUSES MATERIALS
REPORTING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHICH IS EACH BUSINESS SEGMENT
HOUSING MATERIAL DATA INTO A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE. CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
REPORTING SYSTEM. THIS DATABASE
IS ACCESSIBLE BY ALL THE FIRST
RESPONDER COMMUNITIES. PROVIDE
CONFIRMATION ABOUT THE HOUSES
OUT OF BUSINESS IF AN EMERGENCY
WERE TO OCCUR. DECEMBER ASSEMBLY
CARRILLO AND MY COLLEAGUE. LONG
HAVE SHARED THERE ARE BEEN SOME
SIGNIFICANT HOUSE MATURE
INCIDENTS WITHIN THE STATE. POST
INCIDENT REVIEWS IDENTIFY THAT
FIRST RESPONDERS TO DON'T HAVE
THE CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE HAZARDS AT THE FACILITY. AB
TWENTY NINE WILL SYSTEM BRING
ABOUT OF CONSISTENCY TO THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY AND HELP
COOPER IS FINE THE SOVIET THAT
BEEN UTILIZING POLLS FROM
PROPERLY REPORTING. IN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR FUNDAMENTALLY WE
DO NOT WANT TO CREATE FURTHER
BURDENS TO THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY RECORDKEEPING COMPANY
THAT TRANSPORT HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS. HAVE RECORDS TO
COMPLY WITH OTHER TRANSPORTATION
RIGHT- LATER REGULATIONS
INFORMATION PROPOSED MAYBE
TWENTY FIFTY NINE WERE
EXTRAPOLATED FROM EXISTING
RECORD UTILIZED TODAY IT'S JUST
BUILDING ARE MANIFEST. THE TIME
FRAME FOR RECORDKEEPING
PROPOSING AB TWENTY FIFTEEN I
WAS ALSO DEVELOPED FROM OTHER
EXISTING RECORD RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
UNIFIED PROGRAM. IT USUALLY
RETAILS DUNGEONS CLARIFICATION
IN AB TWENTY FIFTY NINE WILL
HELP CLARIFY WHICH FACILITY NEED
TO REPORT HOUSES MATERNAL
PERMISSION INTO THAT STATE
DATABASE. IN LIGHT OF KEEPING
WITH THE FUNDAMENTALS NOT
CREATING ADDITIONAL BURDENS
REPAYMENT AVERAGE STORES AT A
RETAIL FACILITY AND LOOKED UP
OVERALL RESTORE FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNITY TO COME UP WITH THE
PROPOSAL THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT.
THAT IS BEING AB TWENTY FIFTY
NINE- THE COULD PERFORM BOARD
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ENSURE
THAT THIS IMPORTANT STORY. IS
IMPACTFUL WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRKINESS. HIM
MEMBERS FOR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MISTER JOHN. NOW WILL LAW
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND IF NOT THEN- WE
WILL ASK ANYONE WHO HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL OR IS IN
OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DON KEPT KEEP MCCUE KEPT CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION CURRENTLY ON THE BILL
BUT DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS.
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US SAID
JUST TO CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF
APPLICABILITY ERA FOR THE
PROVISIONS OUR MEMBERS ARE
COVERED UNDER THE HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL BUSINESS PLAN-
REPORTING REGULATIONS AS WELL AS
REPORTS INTO SERVERS SYSTEM AND
SO I JUST WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY TO ADD THAT THERE
WOULDN'T BE DUPLICATIVE
REPORTING AND RECORDKEEPING
REQUIREMENTS WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF. WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOGNITION OF
THAT REMAINING ISSUE TO ADDRESS
I'M LOOK FORWARD TO ADDRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU. YES
THE NIGHT I CAN SPEAK FOR MY
STAFF THAT THEY'LL- BE THERE TO
HELP IN ANY WAY THAT'S NEEDED
SO. YOU KNOW NO GOOD BELLY-
PERFECT WHEN IT. WHEN IT STARTS
AND- WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT
THERE IS A TIME LINE SO WE NEED
TO GET THEM STARTED BUT- THEY'LL
BE PLENTY OF TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AND I HOPE WE CAN REACH A
CONSENSUS- SO. WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ONLY THANK YOU. MR
TO SMOKE WHAT WOULD GATHER.
ATION.
AND AGAIN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS PRESS ONE
THEN THEY ARE AT THIS TIME. K.
MAN BOKO TWO ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE DR MILAN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION WE
THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAND BY TO
MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS TO
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL
. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE SECURE AT THIS
TIME. VERY GOOD- YEP COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SHOT QUESTIONS COMMENTS
. MR OUR K. BUT YOU THIRTY GO-
THANK YOU IS CARILLO FOR AT
BRINGING THIS BALLOTS AM I DID
NOT KNOW ABOUT THE INCIDENT LA
BUT HOW FRIGHTENING THAT IS FOR
BOTH THE PARENTS OF THE CHILDREN
AT NEARBY BUT ALSO FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS WHO HAD TO DEAL
WITH THAT- SO I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AROUND. AND THE
RETAIL EXEMPTION I THINK GIVEN
THE SITUATION WE FOUND SADLY WE
HAD TO FIND HER A INCIDENT LIKE
BEST A GAPING HOLE IN OUR LOBBY
OR CORRECTING- BUT I WANT TO
TOUCH ON I THINK WHAT MAKES KEPT
HE WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON WHICH
IS THE FIVE YEAR REQUIREMENT I
KNOW THERE. LOCK THREW FOR.
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS
RIGHT NOW AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
HOLDERS AND- SUPPLIERS
DISTRIBUTORS. TRANSPORTERS
EXCEPT IRAQ- I'M NOT A 100% SURE
HOW THAT ON TOP OF OUR
REGULATIONS HELP SOLVE THE
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
AND IT SEEMS LIKE A- IN SOME
REQUIREMENT THAT. OESN'T SEEM
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS I WAS WONDER IF YOU
COULD. TIMES I THINK THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- MISTER CHAN
CAN PROBABLY ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON THE WORK THAT THE
COOPERS THEMSELVES DO BUT THE
FIVE YEAR REQUIREMENT IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE WORK IN THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
BY CALLIE PA SO. IT'S SIMPLY
ALIGNING TIMELINES FOR THEM BUT
I'LL CERTAINLY LET MISTER JOHN
ADDRESS IT IF POSSIBLE MISTER
YES GO AHEAD MISTER JOHN. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE- THE QUESTION
- THE TIME FRAME WITH DEFAULT
KIND OF BASED ON THE OTHER
RECORD RETENTION- COMPONENTS ARE
BUT ALSO ITS LEADER TO ENSURE
THERE'S NO- I GUESS SOME BASS
RECORD STOP. DISCOURAGED- WHERE-
HERALD HAVE BEEN MOVING- BUT
DEFINITELY- WE'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU IN THE COMMITTEE
TOO YOU KNOW FURTHER YOU KNOW
ABOUT A WAIT. THIS PORTION REYES
WHO I KEEP HEARING IS THAT WERE
ALIGNING WITH OTHER REQUIREMENTS
AND I JUST DON'T SEE THE
NECESSITY OF ADDING ANOTHER
REQUIREMENT UNLESS THERE IS A
WHOLE THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SEE IS WHAT IS THE
WHOLE WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
THROUGH THIS FIVE YEAR I DON'T
KNOW IF THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT
IS ELECTRONIC THIS DOES REQUIRE
ELECTRONIC RECORD KEEPING AND
FIRST. YOU KNOW SMALLER
BUSINESSES CAN BE MORE
BURDENSOME THAN KEEPING A FILE
FOLDER SO I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S THE CHANGER
TRYING TO SEEK IN THE PROBLEM
YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE WITHOUT
FIVE YEAR PEACE THE REST OF THE
BALLET I WANNA. BE CLEAR I
UNDERSTAND. THE MAJORITY OF THE
FACILITIES DO YOU I GUESS THAT
TO SHIPPING TO KEEP KIND OF. YOU
KNOW. WHAT TRACK RECORDS AT THIS
MOMENT- AGAIN. YOU DON'T HE
THOUGHT WE WERE POINT FROM WAS
EXISTING LIKE BUILDING AT THAT
THEY ALREADY KIND OF KEEP US
RECORD SO AGAIN TRYING TO- I
GUESS. KEEP IN MIND WITH. THE
EASE OF- I GUESS BOTH FOR THE
BUSINESS AND WITHOUT CREATING
SOME ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW
REQUIREMENTS OF STUFF THAT THEY
OR YOU'RE KEEPING FROM OTHER
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE WE'RE SPECIFIC. DONE OKAY
SO THIS FINISHED WITH IT SOUNDS
LIKE. WHAT I'VE HEARD NOW TWICE
IS THAT THIS IS BASED ON OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THEY ALREADY HAVE
WHICH MAKES ME BELIEVE THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE REQUIRING A
FIVE YEAR ELECTRONIC RECORD IS
UNNECESSARY. ELSEWHERE THE
AIRPLANE FROM BUT I. MAYBE I
JUST AM NOT GETTING CLARITY AND
WE CAN GET IT AFTER THE HEARING
THAT'S ALSO FINE I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I REALLY
REALLY HOPE. THAT WE DON'T PUT
ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON BUSINESS
WHEN THEY DON'T AREN'T NECESSARY
OR SOLVING A PROBLEM AGAIN THE
OTHER CHANGES IN THIS BILL I
THINK ARE CLEAR AND THAT PEACE.
REMAINS A MYSTERY TO ME SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN CLARIFY IT AND
ENSURE THAT IT'S NOT.
NECESSARILY DEFERRED AS ALWAYS-
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME YOU
SPEND ON THE BILLS AND ASKING
GOOD QUESTIONS- AND I'M SURE WE
CAN RESOLVE THAT AFTER THE
HEARING TODAY. ARE SO I'LL LEAVE
THAT TO THE AUTHOR- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. AND AGAIN WE CAN NOW
GET INVOLVED AS WELL VOLUNTEER
FOLKS- OF VOLUNTEER THE STAFF-
SO I THINK IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO
CLOSE THIS CARILLO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND THE INTENT TO TRY
TO JUST SIMPLY MAKE THE BILL
BETTER NOT CREATE DUPLICATIVE
EFFORTS I WILL SAY WE HAVE A
LARGE STATE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND THEY'RE ONLY EIGHTY ONE COOP
US ACROSS THE STATE. SO I WOULD
ADD THAT THE ADDITIONAL-
ENFORCEMENT OR THE ADDITIONAL
RECORD KEEPING- IS ALSO AN ART
IN RESPONSE TO ENSURING THAT
THESE EIGHTY ONE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE ACCESS TO RECORDS FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME. DEPENDING
ON WHERE THEY'RE BASED HOW
MATERIALS ARE MOVED WHERE
MATERIALS ARE MOVED TO AND
THERE'S CONTINUITY AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE BUT OF COURSE WE'RE-
ALWAYS WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE CREATE LEGISLATION THAT
ULTIMATELY IS AN TO PUT US ON
THAT MEETS THE GOAL OF ENSURING
THE COMMUNITIES. KNOW WHAT
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS IS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE CREATING POLICY
THAT SUPPORTS FIRST RESPONDERS
AND DOESN'T CREATE ADDITIONAL.
HAZARDS IN THEIR OWN WORK SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I WILL I
WILL. SHARE THAT. I GOT INTO
THIS BASE BASED ON THE REALLY
GOOD WORK THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SOUTHEAST HAS DONE TO
ENSURE THE EXITE VERNON
CONTAMINATION PLAN BATTERY PLANT
CONTAMINATION PLANT- DOESN'T
OCCUR AGAIN WHICH IS IN FACT.
THE BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER IN THE STATE IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE BUT NO ONE
KNOWS ABOUT. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE TYPES OF.
EVENTS DON'T OCCUR IN THE
FUTURE. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ORAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND FOR
THEIR SPONSORSHIP OF THIS
MEASURE. AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
TEAM. I TO ENSURE THAT WE GET
THIS RIGHT THIS BILL AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THE
CONCERNS BUT HAS NO OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND IF I MAY
SAY MISTER CHAIR- THIS MAY BE
THE LAST BILL THAT I PRESENT IN
YOUR COMMITTEE IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE
WITH YOU AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE GUIDANCE. WELL- I KNOW YOU
IS ONE OF OUR MOST IDEALISTIC
MEMBERS AND THIS IS THE KIND OF
BILL YOU BRING FORWARD. A BILL
TO HELP PROTECT PEOPLE. AND
DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO CARES
pDISTRICT OR THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE THE NEW YORK THANK YOU-
CHAU I THINK WE CAN HAVE. YES S.
PROMOTION OF. THIRTY SECONDS
VERY GOOD- MADAM SECRETARY. THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
FIFTY NINE CARRY ON. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
BY CORK I'D SMITH OF MEDISAVE NO
OPEN TILL I CAN READ THE
AMENDMENT SORT OF REPROACH
PROPOSAL LATER TO LOOK AT IT
THANK OKAY SMITH NOW. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN POWER CAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN
. MATHIS MATHIS I MURATSUCHI
WHAT A TO G. I WALDRON. WE HAVE
FIVE VOTES WITHOUT. MOTION
PASSES AND- I'M SURE MISTER
SMITH WELL WE'LL BRING YOU ALONG
LATER. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
NEED. ALL RIGHT SO WE NOW NEED
AUTHOR- MISTER CHANG. AND. YES
MISTER RIVAS SAU. YEAH THEY'RE
ON THEIR WAY. OKAY WHAT I WOULD
DO SOME ADD ON. YEAH YEAH.
DURING THE INTERVIEW CARE ACT.
AND CONFIGURE I'M- I DON'T
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIFTY NINE.
CAREER WE JUST WENT THROUGH.
ITEMS THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
THREE BLANCA RUBIO THE VOTE SETS
AT FOUR ZERO ONE OF TWO G. BRETT
TO GI SO THAT BRINGS IT TO FIVE
ZERO IS THAT ONCE. PASSED YES
THERE. I SUBMIT THIS IS- AS VICE
CHAIR SMITH ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE BLANCA
RUBIO SMITH NOT VOTING OKAY SIR. I AM NUMBER SEVEN IS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CORK THE
VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO WHAT IT TOO
CHEAP MURATSUCHI I. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS IT FIVE ZERO. WHAT
TO CHANGE WOULD HAVE TO CHECK.
WELL THIS WILL KEEP US BUSY
WHILE- IT'S VERY GOOD TO SEE
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AND
YOU HAVE THREE BILLS YOUR
FREQUENT FLYER. AND ALL THAT
WORK YOU KNOW AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT YOU ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR WATER
QUALITY. ARE YOU MAY PROCEED ON
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE. WELL
I AM SORRY TWENTY ONE OH SIX
TWENTY ONE OF SIX WHAT DOCTOR
CORK IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. AND COLLEAGUES- SO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE JUST AS I
YOU KNOW FIRST ONE AT THE START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
YOU KNOW THIS OP I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON- APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
ANALYSIS NOT ONLY FOR THIS BILL
BUT FOR THE TWO UPCOMING BILLS-
BUT THIS LEGISLATION IS ON THE
BILL TWO ONE ZERO SIX EIGHT AT
SIX TO MODERNIZE OUR STATE'S
APPROACH TO STORMWATER. BUT
WHICH IS THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
US SOME WATER SOME POLLUTION IN
OUR STATE- AND IT'S POLLUTION
THAT CAN CAUSE SOME SERIOUS
PUBLIC IN ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AS WE KNOW THE STORM
WATER IS THE WATER THAT RUNS OFF
OF ROOFS SIDEWALKS IN OTHER PAID
WATER THEN IT DRAINS INTO RUNOFF
CHANNELS THAT CRISSCROSS THROUGH
THE LANDSCAPE AND ALONG THE WAY
THE WATER RUN OFF IT ACCUMULATED
TOXIC SLEW OF CHEMICALS. OIL
FERTILIZER TRASH HEAVIER HARD
METALS AND OTHER POLLUTANTS. B.
B. FOR THE B. AFFORD ENTERS A
STORM DRAIN AND EVENTUALLY MAKES
ITS WAY OUT INTO THE OCEAN. SO
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE FEDERAL
CLEAN WATER ACT THIS IS THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THAT-
FEDERAL LAW WE HAVE MADE A LOT
OF PROGRESS IS THE STATE NO WE
HAVE- WE HAVE PROVEN AS A STATE
THAT WE CAN CLEAN AND RESTORE
OUR WATERWAYS IN MANY PARTS. OF
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY LITTLE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
REDUCING STORM WATER- SOME
POLLUTION- THE- ACROSS OUR
STATE. AND IT'S BECOMING A
GROWING PROBLEM EVEN AS OUR
CURRENT- ARE PERMITS JUST
IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON THE
REGULATED- THE- THE COMMUNITY.
THE RESULT IS THAT- ESPECIALLY
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED- SOME
COMMUNITIES WERE NOT ACHIEVING
OUR WATER QUALITY GOALS. AND
WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO DO SO. SO
THIS LEGISLATION SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN THREE WAYS
FIRST AND MORE IMPORTANTLY- THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO CONDUCT A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. BUT TO TAKE
A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT HOW THE
STATE'S STORMWATER PROGRAM CAN
ACHIEVE SOME BETTER RESULTS AT
LESS COST TO THE PERMIT THESE.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS SIMPLY NOT
WORKING FOR ANYONE. AND WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO GET BACK TO
THE DRAWING BOARD. AND SECOND.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO CREATE A
NEW PERMIT. A PERMIT THAT WOULD
COVER SOME CURRENTLY UNREGULATED
SOURCES OF STORMWATER- SOME
POLLUTION. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
THE BURDEN OF COMPLIANCE IS MORE
FAIRLY. DISTRIBUTED ACROSS ALL
SOURCES OF STORMWATER. AND WOULD
ALSO CREATE REGULATORY
CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND FINALLY THIS
BILL WOULD MODERNIZE OUR
STORMWATER DATA SYSTEMS. ARE SO
THAT THEY WORK BETTER FOR BOTH
REGULATORS AND- THE- PERMITIR
THIS- AND TOGETHER THESE
PROPOSALS SEEK TO PUT US BACK ON
TRACK. AB THE C. TO PUT IT BACK
ON TRACK TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
ELIMINATING THESE DANGEROUS
STORM WATER- SOME POLLUTION
WHICH AGAIN IS THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF WATER- SOME POLLUTION
ACROSS OUR ENTIRE STATE. BECAUSE
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE CLEAN WATER
TO ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WE
MUST DO SO REGARDLESS OF INCOME.
AND STATUS OR ZIP CODE YOU KNOW
ACCOMPLISHING THIS IS CRITICAL.
I IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS
WE HAVE APPRECIATE. ALL OF THEIR
ENGAGEMENT- TO FURTHER REFINE
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION
AND WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
SEAN BOSWELL OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE. AND
NICOLE I HILL OF THE OUR WATER
L. A. COALITION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU CHECK WORK AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SEAN BOTHWELL I AND-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COAST COMPLIANCE AND
I WOULD URGE YOUR- I'D VOTE AND
SUPPORT ON SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE
OF SIX- I WANTED TO ADDRESS
SECTION THREE OF THE BILL WHICH
IS THE COMMERCIAL. INSTITUTIONAL
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT-
THAT NUMBER RIVAS OF MENTION
JUST A SECOND AGO. SO WE REALLY
SEE THIS PERMIT IS AN EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY UP BECAUSE IT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH FOUR THINGS ONE IT
WOULD ADDRESS A CURRENTLY
COMPLETELY UNREGULATED SOURCE OF
STORMWATER POLLUTION. TO IT
WOULD REDUCE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CURRENT LIABILITY
FOR THAT RUNOFF THAT'S COMING
OFF THOSE COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
AND THEN INTO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUNICIPAL STORM
DRAIN. IT WOULD INCENTIVIZE
STORMWATER CAPTURE AND RE USE
AND COULD PROVIDE- A CREATIVE
SOURCE OF CAR SHARING BETWEEN
THE COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES AND
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD
MORE CENTRALIZED STORMONT TO
CAPTURE- ON A MORE REGIONAL
BASIS. I IN LOS ANGELES THE U.
S. EPA IN THE REGIONAL BOARD ARE
ABOUT TO RELEASE ONE OF THESE
COMMERCIAL STORMONT PERMITS- IN
APRIL. THEY ANTICIPATE IT WILL
BE ADOPTED BY THIS SEPTEMBER SO
ONLY SIX MONTHS AFTER- THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT- HAS
STARTED. THIS LEGISLATION IS
GOING TO GIVE THE STATE WATER
BOARD TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
AFTER THE L. A. PERMAN IS
ADOPTED TO SEE HOW THE PERMIT IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED TO SEE ANY
CONCERNS THAT MIGHT BE OCCURRING
BETWEEN THE COMMERCIAL FACILITY
IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AT THE
IRON THOSE OUT FOR STATEWIDE
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
OUT ALL OF THE PROBLEM AN ISSUE
AREAS. I DON'T BE CLEAR AT THIS
LEGISLATION ONLY REQUIRES THE
STATE BOARD TO RELEASE A PUBLIC
DRAFT BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND THAT'S REALLY
WHEN THE OFFICIAL PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS BEGINS- AND
SO WE THINK THERE'S MORE THAN
ENOUGH TIME. FOR THE STATE TO
SEE HOW THAT PERMITS WORKING AND
TO MAKE SURE IT'S WORKABLE FOR
EVERY REGION- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I ALSO WANTED TO ADDRESS
WHY STATEWIDE ORDERS IS
APPROPRIATE INSTEAD NINE
INDIVIDUAL REGIONAL. PERMITS
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE
ON OUR FINGER TIPS THAT. WOULD
ALLOW US TO PETITION EACH OF THE
REGIONS TO DO ONE OF THESE.
PERMITS INDIVIDUALLY. BUT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES TO ONE
HAVE SOME STATEWIDE CONSISTENCY
SO THEY SO THEY KNOW WHAT THE
RULES OF THE GAME ARE. AND TO.
IF THEY HAVE MULTIPLE PROPERTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THEY WOULD
HAVE THE SAME TYPE OF COMPLIANCE
PATH AND SO THERE WOULD BE A
CLEAR CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
STATE. IT ALSO BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE. FOR THE STATE TO DO
ONE PERMIT. THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE SEQUEL AND THAT THAT
THAT'S A QUITE A BIG BURDEN ON
THE STATE WATER BOARD. RATHER
THAN EACH REGIONAL BOARD DO
THEIR OWN PERMIT AND THEIR OWN
SEQUEL PROCESS. WE REALLY FEEL
LIKE IT PROVIDES A STATE ENOUGH
TIME- WHILE PROVIDING. A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY OF GETTING THIS
PERMIT- COMPLETED. SOME
COLLUSION- AS MEMBER RIVAS SAID
OF THE COMPANY STORE PROGRAM
IT'S NOT WORKING IT'S TIME TO
MODERNIZE IT- IT'S TIME FOR US
TO LOOK AT A HOLISTIC APPROACH.
TO STORMWATER MANAGEMENT TO
IDENTIFY SOURCES OF POLLUTION
AND CONTROL THEM AT ITS SOURCE.
AND TO ENCOURAGE STORM WATER
CAPTURE AND THESE ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
WITH THE REGULATED COMMUNITY-
SINCE LAST YEAR'S LEGISLATION.
TO REALLY FIND AREAS OF COMMON
GROUND THAT WE CAN WORK ON
TOGETHER AND WE ALL AGREE WE
NEED TO DO MOVING FORWARD. SO
WITH THAT- I THINK YOU IN AFTER
ABOUT. THERE ARE VERY GOOD- SO
PHONE MODEL- LET'S SEE NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE COAL- HAIL
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR WATER
LA COALITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
AND THE CALL CAN YOU SPEAK UP
NOW. THANK YOU FOR CORRECTING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
NICOLE HYLTON HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE OUR WATER L. A.
COALITION AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWENTY ONE OF
SIX. OUR WATER LA IS A DIVERSE
COALITION OF COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS PHILLY
COUNTY UNITED TO CREATE A STRONG
WATER FEATURE FOR LOS ANGELES
AND AB TWENTY ON A SIX CRITICAL
TO OUR GOAL TO SECURE CLEAN SAFE
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE WATER
HERE. CALIFORNIA AND LOS ANGELES
IN PARTICULAR HAS FAILED TO
FULLY REALIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CAPTURE STORM WATER AND TREATED
AS A RESOURCE THAT THAN JUST TO
PUT IN AB TWENTY ONE SIX WILL
MAKE STATE WATER BOARD TOOK A
HARD LOOK AT THE CURRENT TIME
WATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. AND
REQUIRE MORE MODERN HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO PREVENTING
STORMWATER POLLUTANT AT THEIR
STORES KIDDING. ALL WATER AT THE
BALLOT.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YOU HEAR ME.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YEAH THE VOLUME
BUTTONS WILL CONTROL THE ARM.
THE VOLUME BUTTONS WILL CONTROL
THE SPEAKER OUT ON THE D. X.
EIGHTY SO THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING ON AREN'T
GOING RIGHT.
DEPENDS. THAT RISES- YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HARD.
WITH THE- YEAH WE CAN. EXTRA
THAT'S AGAIN. WHAT ME WE CAN
HERE- GOOD THANK YOU FOR FIXING
THAT- SO WHERE WERE WE OH YES
HAVE HEARD FROM WITHIN ROOM NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO THE PHONE
LINE. AND MISTER READ EIGHTEEN
T. IF YOU COULD GIVE US OUR- AS
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO EITHER ARE
OPPOSED OR IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX. ARE TO SPEAK
AND TO GIVE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU. IMAGINE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL START WITH LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KIRTI HUGHES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE AT THE PRODUCERS I WE
HAVE TO TAKE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL- BUT YOU
AFTER SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED- BY THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE PARTICULARLY
WITH REGARD TO SECTION FOUR. AND
SOME WORRY THAT THEY MAY HAVE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WITH REGARD TO OUR REMOVING
DISCRETION FROM THE REGIONAL AND
STATE WATER BOARDS WE WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU. NEXT
TO HEADLINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
BOB SPIEGEL SENIOR POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXGEN ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ERIN WILL
BE HALF OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF AB. AT TWENTY ONE SIX. NEXT A
LITTLE AND FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM KAREN KALLEN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STAR WATER
QUALITY ASSOCIATION WE HAVE NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THE TIME THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
FASTER AND MORE AT THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO- TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THAT
WE RAISED IN OUR COMMON LETTER
THAT WITH. ME. AND NEXT WILL GO
TO ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS TO
HELP WITH THE SITUATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER TERRY
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THEN- THERE
BEING NO ONE ELSE MISTER SMITH.
TO FILL UP WITH COUPLE OF
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE BECAUSE I
KNOW A NEW CONSTRUCTION THEY GOT
STORMWATER. RETENTION PONDS COST
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
I'M WONDERING IF THIS BILL WOULD
TRIGGER OMER REMODELER PAVING OF
THE PARKING LOT TO TRIGGER THAT
SO THEY GOTTA GO TO STORM WATER
RETENTION POND. OUR SYSTEM HUNG.
MORE CONSTRUCTION LANGUAGE AND
BEFORE BUT THAT IS MY CONCERN
BECAUSE THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
WE'RE JUST GOING TO PAY THE
PARKING BUT IT'S GOING TO ADD
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MORE ALL
DEPENDS ON WHICH- HOW BIG A SPUR
FOOTAGE IS ON PARTICULAR. STRIP
MALL MARKET INDUSTRIAL WHATEVER
THAT AND THAT'S MY OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN ADDRESS IT OR
NOT. SO WE TRIED OUR BEST IN THE
LEGISLATION TO NOTS. BE
RESTRICTIVE OR NOT TAKE ANY
DISCUSSION FROM THE WATER BOARDS
ON HOW THEY'RE GONNA CUT THE
PERMITS WE TRY TO KEEP IT VERY
HIGH LEVEL- AND- BUT FROM WHAT
WE KNOW THAT'S COMING OUT OF LOS
ANGELES AND I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
BORDER. THE IN THIS IS ONE OF
THE REASONS I THINK YOU SEE SOME
SUPPORT FROM SOME OF THE
EXISTING STORMWATER PERMIT TV'S.
OR YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE BUT- IS BASICALLY IT THE
WE EXPECT THE PERMITS HAVE THREE
OF THE FLEXIBLE OPTIONS FOR
COMPLIANCE. IT'S A ONE OF THEM
IS WHAT WHAT YOU JUST SAID TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD STORMWATER CAPTURE
ON THE PROPERTY ITSELF. THE
OTHER TWO IS EITHER JUST ME-
WATER PLACED ENTERED SO IF YOU
IF YOU TO RUNOFF COMING FROM THE
PROPERTY HAS NO POLLUTION IN IT.
THEN YOU'RE IN COMPLIANCE AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BUILD ANYTHING
IT'S THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
OPTIONS. THE LAST. THE LAST
OPTION WOULD BE- TO. TO PAY INTO
A DO A COST SHARE WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN AGAIN THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD BUILD THE
LARGER STORMWATER CAPTURE ON
MORE CENTRALIZED. TEACHER AND
THAT THAT'S SAVES A LOT OF COST
BECAUSE IT IT. BASICALLY
CAPTURES ALL THE SOMEONE TREATS
ALL SOMEONE FROM EVERYONE UP UP
IN THE WATERSHED. BECAUSE AT THE
CONCERT WITH FIG ALRIGHT THE
SMALL WATER TEST SYSTEM FOR JUST
SAY THE BLOCK NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHO'S GOING TO MONITOR TEST THAT
SO THEN IT GOES INTO THE
STORMWATER SYSTEM L. A. RIVER.
WHO'S GONNA TESTED THERE AND
WHO'S GONNA TEST OF JUST BEFORE
IT HITS THE OCEAN. BECAUSE WE
KNOW AFTER STORM WATER RAINFALL
IT COMES SOMETIMES A BEACH IS
CLOSE FROM ALL OF THAT
UNDERSTAND TRYING TO KEEP CLEAN
WATER. BUT HOW MANY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MIGHT BE ADDED TO THIS
COST THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN
IN WHO'S GOING TO PAY.
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS AND SOME ARE GONNA
BE ABLE TO AFFORD. IT WOULD LOSE
MORE BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
GO AHEAD MISS OUR QUE HAN. THANK
YOU SO I THINK. WHEN I READ THE
BILL I WAS A LITTLE STUMPED BY
SORT OF WHAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED
TODAY WHICH IS THE LACK OF
CLARITY AND WHAT IT IS WE'RE
ACTUALLY. I HAVE AT THE END.
THESE NEW STORMWATER PERMITS
WILL LOOK LIKE WHICH- I'LL BE
HONEST MAKES ME A LITTLE UNEASY-
AND SO. I HEAR YOU'RE DOING THAT
BUT I GUESS PART OF ME THEN
QUERIES WHETHER. THE TIMING OF
THIS IS OFFER YOU'RE WAITING
UNTIL THE L. A. PERMIT COMES OUT
YOU CAN SEE HOW IT GOES YOU CAN
LEARN FROM IT THE STATE WATER
CAN LEARN FROM IT AND THEN THEY
WILL IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DO
THIS. BASED ON THOSE LEARNINGS
IS WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY AFTER
THE TIME I CAME FROM. SO I GUESS
CREE WHY WE'RE DOING THIS BEFORE
WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN LA. WHERE
WE PRESUPPOSING THAT THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA NOW RATHER THAN.
WAITING A YEAR AND SEEING I
GUESS CAN SOMEBODY ADDRESS THAT
. WELL I YOU HAVE TO TURN OVER
SHOT BUT I THINK YOU KNOW THE
REASON WE'RE DOING THIS IS
BECAUSE- THIS IS A PROBLEM THE
BIG PROBLEM AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A VERY PUBLIC
PROCESS IN LA AND THEY'RE ABOUT
YOU KNOW VERY SOON TO- PPD IN
THEIR OFFICIAL- MAYO THE RELEASE
OF- THEIR REGULATION THEY'RE
PERMITTING PROCESS AND THEY CAN
BEGIN THAT PUBLIC PROCESS- AND
SO CERTAINLY WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
LOT OF CLARITY ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING IN A
MATTER OF DAYS OR WEEKS. OF
TRYING TO POINT OUT THAT IT
COULD NOT. ALSO SAKE SO. WE HAVE
THE EVIDENCE THAT DEMONSTRATES
THAT THIS POLLUTION IS COMING
OFF THESE FACILITIES AND UNDER
THE CLEAN WATER ACT THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED NOW AND TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST I HAD THE
OPTION OF WE COULD WIN TEACH
REGIONAL BOARD AND PETITION EACH
OF THEM OR WE THOUGHT THIS WAS
THE MORE KIND COST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO DO IT IN MORE RESPONSIBLE WAY
TO DO IT BECAUSE WE BUILD OUT
THE TIME FOR IT. AND SO THE LA
ONE IS GOING TO BE ADOPTED IN
SEPTEMBER AND WE KNOW WHAT'S IN
IT IT HASN'T HIT THE STREET YET
BUT I KNOW WHAT'S IN THE ORDER I
THINK THIS SORT OF PROPERTIES
UNDERSTAND THEY'VE ALREADY HAD
CYCLE TO MAKE SO WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO BE IN THERE AND I THINK
THE IDEA IS RIGHT NOW IN THIS
THIS GETS TO THE OTHER POINT
MADE. RIGHT NOW THE
MUNICIPALITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEY'RE THE ONES ON
THE HOOK THEY'RE THE ONES RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE INCURRING THE
LIABILITY COSTS FROM THIS RUNOFF
IT'S GOING INTO THEIR M. S. FOR
THEIR THE ONES THAT HAVE THE
MONITOR FOR IT AND NOW THEY'RE
THE ONES RIGHT NOW THAT ARE IN
CHARGE OF IT IT'S A REALLY WE
SEE THIS AS- A LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD SO THAT EVERYONE IS
EQUALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTION OF THIS THE STORM
WATER RUNOFF. AND YET WE BUILT
OUT TIME TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TO ANYTHING HAS TO HIT THE
STREETS FOR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
BUT THE STATE BOARD'S GONNA
START WORKING ON THIS A MEDIALLY
ENDED IN FACT WHEN WE TALK TO
THEM THEY ONLY WANTED US TO
REALLY WAIT UNTIL THE YOU KNOW
TO SEE HOW THE PUBLIC COMMENT
CAME OUT AND HOW THE REVISED
THAT JUST LA PERMIT FORGET THE
PART ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
THEY JUST WANT TO SEE WHAT KIND
OF ISSUES GOT REYES. AND SO WE
BUILT IN EXTRA TIME JUST AND
REALLY I THINK WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IS THIS UNIQUE FEATURE
THE ALTERNATE COMPLIANCE PATH OF
THE FACILITY BEING ABLE TO PAY-
THE WITH THE MUNICIPALITY TO DO
A CARSHARE PROGRAM THAT'S REALLY
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE PART TO BE WORKED
OUT BUT NO ONE IS FORCING THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE TO DO
THOSE AGREEMENTS AND I THINK TWO
AND A HALF YEARS TO CUT HIGHER
NOT HOW DOES AND WILL USE WILL
WORK. IT IS SUFFICIENT TIME TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- AND IF IT'S
NOT. THE STATE BORDER TAKE LONG.
BEFORE SOME. AND ALL. KNOWN
LOCAL. IS BEING REQUIRED TO DO.
OF THE ANY OF THIS KIND OF CAR
SHARING AGREEMENT WITH THEM IT'S
JUST THAT. ONE OF THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE. AND AGAIN
MUNICIPALITIES. HAVE TO DO THIS
ANYWAY. SO IT CAN I JUST AND
MAYBE USE THAT AS MY APOLOGIZE
IN ADVANCE IF YOU DID SO
REGIONAL. REGIONAL BOARDS COPIES
TO DO THIS ALREADY CAN THE STATE
BOARD DO A STATEWIDE PERMIT NOW.
OR WE ENABLING THEM TO DO
SOMETHING THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO. THEY CAN. THEY
CAN DO IT NOW IF THEY IF THEY
WANTED TO YES. OKAY SO. WHAT
HAVE THEY WAIT AND DO THEY WANT
TO DO IS STATEWIDE AND I ALSO
THINK ABOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I WANT TO I
ACTUALLY SHOULD HAVE STARTED BY
SAYING. HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO.
HAVE A RIVAS FOR HIS DEDICATION.
TO STORMWATER RUNOFF IT IS AS HE
POINTED OUT. A REALLY BIG ISSUE-
AND ONE THAT WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE DOING IT IN THE
SMARTEST WAY. AND GIVEN SORT OF
WHAT I FOUND TO BE A LITTLE BIT
OF THE- VACANT H. OR- OF THE
BILL AS IT STANDS TODAY. I JUST
HAD A LOT OF QUESTIONS SO CAN
YOU AS A THIRD. YEAH AND I CAN
JUST THE VAGUE NATURE OF IT. WE
DID THAT ON PURPOSE ALMOST AS A
COMMITMENT TO SOME OF THE- THE-
THE PROPERTIES AND THE FOLKS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO ON
STORMWATER STUFF BECAUSE- IN
FACT WE TOOK AMENDMENTS. ALSO
TALKING TO CALCHAMBER. BECAUSE
NO ONE WANTED. OUR BILL LANGUAGE
TIED SPECIFICALLY TO THE L. A.
PERMIT WE TOOK THAT OUT. BECAUSE
OF THE OTHER FOLKS ASK FOR THAT-
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE TRY TO KEEP
A HIGH LEVEL. I ALSO JUST WANTED
TO BE RESPECTFUL. LAST YEAR WHEN
WE ARE IN THIS COMMITTEE OF THE
KNOT TYING THE BOARD'S HANDS
GIVING THEM ALL THEIR
DISCRETION. SO THAT THEY CAN
DEFINE. I KNOW ONE OF THE ISSUES
WAS HOW LARGE OF A FACILITIES IS
GOING TO COVER. AND JUST SO
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT RIGHT NOW IN
THE LA PERMITS THEY'RE PROPOSING
A FIVE ACRES WHICH IS A FAIRLY
LARGE FOR. OF PARKING. THOSE ARE
THE TYPE OF DISCUSSION THAT I
DON'T WANT TO. SELF IMPOSE INTEL
THE WATER BOARD WHAT TO DO SO
THAT'S WHY WE LEFT IT. OPEN BUT
ALSO WERE. IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME MORE DETAILS OF WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS I'M FINE WITH
THAT WE WERE TRYING TO.
COMPROMISE WITH THAT THE FOR THE
FOLKS- AND THEN THE WATER BOARD.
WHAT IS. THIS OKAY WHATEVER YOU
MAKE SURE YOU'RE SPEAKING INTO
THE MICROPHONE. SO ASK THE STATE
WATER WHAT HAVE THEY WEIGHED IN
ON THIS AND THINK IF THEY ARE
YOU HAVE A STORY BUT DON'T
APPEAR TO BE RIGHT. ACCENTING RV
CAGES ANSWER QUESTION WE ARE
SCHEDULED TO ENGAGE WITH WATER
BOARD BUT LATER THIS WEEK OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL THREE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION OKAY. AND SO I DON'T
WANNA SPEAK FOR THEM BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THE
L. A. ORDER. AND I THINK THEY'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL THAT
IT HAS. BECAUSE AGAIN IT.
REGULATE SOMETHING THAT'S
CURRENTLY ON REGULATED. THAT'S
NOW THE MUNICIPALITIES
LIABILITY. AND IT CREATES THESE
ALL THESE. FLEXIBLE OPTIONS THAT
WE REALLY DIDN'T HAVE AN PERMITS
BEFORE AND THEY'RE EXCITED
ABOUT. AND THAT'S WHY IT'S IN
THIS BILL MODERNIZING STORMWATER
IS BASE SEE THIS IS THE WAVE OF
THE FUTURE. AND SO I THINK THEY
ARE EXCITED ABOUT IT NOT IN AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ONE BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO THEM
OFFICIALLY YET. BUT FROM TALKS
WITH THEM LEADING UP TO THIS I
THINK. THEY LIKE THE CONCEPT OF
THE GOING FORTH. GOT IT I'M- SO
I MEAN. AGAIN I THINK YOU KNOW.
I GUESS THE QUESTION BEFORE US
IS DO WE FORCE THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO DO THE STATEWIDE PERMIT
GIVEN THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO IT- BECAUSE WE
THINK SO I GUESS WE'RE MAKING
THE DECISION WE THINK STATEWIDE
IS BETTER THAN A REGIONAL
APPROACH RIGHT I MEAN I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I'M HEARING. IS
REALLY THE QUESTION BEFORE US
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE CAN SAY
IT'S GOING TO BE A FIVE ACRE
PERMIT IT'S GOING TO BE HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT AND WE HAVE NONE OF THOSE
DETAILS. IN THE LANGUAGE WE ARE
MERELY. ASKING THE STATE BOARD.
TO DO A STATEWIDE PERMIT AGAIN
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE LA. ORDER
SO WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THE BASIS
ON WHICH THEY'RE DOING THAT. SO
THAT'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS I'M-
AND NOT A LOT OF ANSWERS AND SO
I GUESS MY- I MEAN I GUESS MY
REAL GOT HERE IS SAYING YOU KNOW
THIS ISN'T THE MOMENT FOR THIS
EVEN IF THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
THING WE SHOULD DO- OF THE
TIMING IS REALLY THE QUESTION.
THAT I HAVE BEFORE ME AND- I
GUESS AND YOU DECIDE BUT I WILL
SAY THAT I DO REALLY APPRECIATE
THE PEACE OF THE BILL THAT
MODERNIZES THE DATABASE I THINK
WE DO A HORRIBLE JOB OF THE
GOVERNMENT ON DATA. INSTEAD IT
LEADS TO- IN ACTION AND- THE
FAILURE TO REALLY- BE SMART
ABOUT OUR MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON THE STREET. YEAH I
KNOW I APPRECIATE- THOSE
COMMENTS AND I THINK WHEN YOU-
ASSESS THIS PROBLEM HOW SOME
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE OF
COLOR ARE IMPACTED MORE SO HAN
OTHERS I THINK CREATING A
STATEWIDE- CONSISTENCY WHEN
COMES ISSUES INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT RATHER THAN TO HAVE
THIS PATCHWORK OF- OF- YOU KNOW
. OF THESE PERMITS ACROSS THE
STATE IN THESE DIFFERENT- THESE-
THESE PROCESSES THAT NEED TO
OCCUR WITH- YOU KNOW ALL THE ALL
THE DIFFERENT BY MAIL IMPACTS
AND YOU KNOW SOMETHING IN ME
TIMELY STONE. IF YOU DON'T TAKE
A LOT OF TIMES OF HAVING A-
STATEWIDE- PROCESS IS IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY FOR STATE LIKE OURS.
OKAY MISC ARE YOU FINISHED OKAY
MISS GARCIA. NOT THINK YEAH I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION I THOUGHT
A COUPLE COMMENTS ON THIS BILL-
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE L. A.
RIVER AND THE THING GABLE RIVER
WHICH IS THE OTHER MAJOR- FLOOD
CHANNEL STORMWATER. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT ACTUALLY BOOK
AND MY DISTRICT I THE BOOK IN A
DISTRICT THAT'S HEAVY LATINO
IMMIGRANT WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITY AND FOR FIFTY YEARS-
THE COMMUNITY THAT THE- CURRENT
LAWS HAVE BEEN WORK FOR US-
IT'S- A BASE AND THAT'S FULL OF
COPPER KDM SEEING LET OIL-
DANGERS LIKE TERRY AND TRASH.
ANY GIVEN DAY OF THE WEEK IS THE
REALITY THAT WE LIVE IN AND SO
THE CURRENT LAW HASN'T WORKED
UNTIL WE DO NEED A STATE WHERE
I'VE HAD TO MAKE SURE THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT. CONTINUE TO BE
LEFT BEHIND ARE NO LONGER LEFT
BEHIND THE TIMING FEELS
UNCOMFORTABLE I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAILS I STILL
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT. BUT WE'RE
REALLY EARLY IN THE PROCESS THIS
YEAR OR NOT EARLY IN THIS
PROCESS THIS IS A DISCUSSION I
STARTED- PREVIOUSLY- ELEVEN
MYSTERY OF US. AND IT WE WILL BE
HAVING MORE DETAILS FROM THE
ALLEY. AND WITHIN. OR WEEKS TOPS
REALLY AREN'T REALLY ON AND SO
WE HAVE.A LOT OF TIME TO HAMMER
THINGS OUT. AND THEN START TO
IMPLEMENT- THINGS ALONG THE WAY
AND SO. I WOULD SAY THAT THE
QUESTIONS YOU'RE ASKING ARE
IMPORTANT ARE IMPORTANT TO ME
ALSO BECAUSE I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S ENOUGH DETAIL
TO THAT. OVER PROMISING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS WILL BECOME A
REALITY IN WITH ONLY TO MY TIME
TO GET READY SO THAT NOTHING
GETS STUCK THAT'S ALSO REALITY
WE LEFT WITH. AND SO I
APPRECIATE. THOSE QUESTIONS BUT
THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE TALKING
ABOUT. ARE ARE VERY CONCENTRATED
ON. BASED ON RACE AND
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS. ACROSS THE
STATE AND SO I WANT TO THANK- I
WANTED THINK INVITE YOU TO JOIN
US AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THOSE
DETAILS NOW AND- NOT LATER
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE DETAILS
REALLY QUICKLY BUT FROM THE
CITY. FROM THE ALLEY REGION.
OKAY MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
. IT MISTER BOTHWELL YES- C. E.
START TALKING ABOUT THE- THE
CONCERN THAT I KNOW MY CITIES
HAVE RAISED- WHICH IS THE THAT
THE HIGH SCHOOL THE HIGH COST OF
A COMPLIANCE OF FOR CITIES- IN
MY HEARING YOU CORRECTLY I HEAR
THAT THE CALCHAMBER RAISING
CONCERNS AND I DON'T SEE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES ARE ALL THE
CITIES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IS THE BASIC APPROACH OF
THIS BILL TO MAKE POLLUTERS PAY
THE CLEAN UP THEIR OWN MESS SO
THAT CITIES DON'T HAVE TO BE SET
UP WITH THE COST OF CLEANUP.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD WAY TO
SUMMARIZE IT YEAH OKAY- I WILL
SAY SO WE WERE HAVING TALKS WITH
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW TO. FIX IT-
WITH THE LEAGUE- WE'VE BEEN
MOSTLY WORKING WITH CATS ONE OF
WHICH IS THE CONTEST THE STORM
WATER STAKEHOLDERS KAREN WHO
SPOKE EARLIER. WITH A MOSTLY
WORKING WITH THEM- SO WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING WITH THEM WE DO
THINK WE'LL WE'LL GET TO A
SUPPORT POSITION THERE'S JUST
SOME MORE MINUTES SO WE'VE BEEN
TAKING AMENDMENTS AND DISCUSSING
THINGS AS WE'VE BEEN MOVING
FORWARD- WITH THEM AND BUT A
WITH- ACCOUNTS WERE. SPEAKING
FOR MUNICIPAL YOU'RE SPEAKING
FOR MUNICIPALITIES SUIT I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THEM BUT LARGELY
THAT'S WHO THEY REPRESENT ON
STORM WATER. WHAT KIND OF THINGS
OKAY. GREAT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
AFTER I HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS-
FOR OF ALL EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO
WHEN I STARTED ON CITY COUNCIL
THEY SAID YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS
STORM WATER MANDATE. AND THE WAY
IT LOOKS IS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO BUILD A SECOND- WATER
PURIFICATION SYSTEM JUST TO DEAL
WITH STORMWATER. WHICH IS A FEW
BILLION DOLLARS- SO. MAYBE IT'S
JUST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS BUT IT
WAS MORE THAN THE CITY FELL TO
COULD AFFORD- AND NO WAY TO
FINANCE IT SO THIS IS A WAY TO
FINANCE BUT- I'M TRYING TO
VISUALIZE SO YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE L. A. SIS THE L. A-
ROSS THIS IS BUT IT'S ONLY FOR A
SMALL PART OF THE CITY RIGHT
JUST A PARTICULAR. A DRAINAGE
BASIN CORRECT IT'S EL CERRITO
SPENT AND BIGGEST CHANNEL. OKAY
SO IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THE
WHOLE OF L. A. COUNTY. NOT
CURRENTLY NO SO THE COURT CASE
THAT- REQUIRED THEM TO GO
FORWARD WITH THAT REQUIRED THE
EPA TO GO FORWARD WITH IT. ON
HOW MUCH I CAN DISCUSS AND- BUT-
THE EPA WANTED TO JUST DO WHAT
THE COURT SAID TO DO- AND NOT
SPEAKING FOR THE WATER BOARDS
BUT I THINK THEY WERE THINKING
WELL THIS IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
TO DO IT MORE BROADLY THAN JUST
THAT WHAT THE COURT SAID SO ARE
YOU ENVISIONING THAT. SOMETIME
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. EVERY PARKING LOT
GREATER THAN FIVE ACRES WOULD
HAVE TO START PAYING INTO A FUND
OR COME UP WITH SOME SORT OF.
MITIGATION EVERYONE IN THE STATE
. SO COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES THAT
ARE FIVE ACRES OR MORE SO THE
WAY THE CLEAN WATER ACT WORKS
THERE NEEDS TO BE A NEXUS
BETWEEN THE FACILITY AND CAUSING
A SIGNIFICANT- CONTRIBUTION OF
POLLUTION INTO. A WATERWAY AND
SO WHERE THERE IS THE EVIDENCE
FOR THAT THAT IS WHERE THE STATE
WATER BOARD USING THEIR
DISCRETION WOULD. THIS WOULD BE-
BASICALLY TAKEN ALL OF L. A.
COUNTY YEP ALL OF EVERY COUNTY.
THE OTHER WORDS- EVERY COUNTY
THAT HAS A PARKING LOT GREATER
THAN FIVE ACRES WHICH IS
CERTAINLY ALL OF THE- URBAN
COUNTIES IN SUBURBAN COUNTIES-
YOU KNOW MAYBE THAT ALPINE BUT
JUST ABOUT EVERYWHERE ELSE. SO
IT'S FACILITY THE FACILITY AND
SO NOT A GRAND TOTAL OF FIVE
ACRES FOR THAT COUNTY BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THE COUNTY THAT'S GOING
TO BE UNDER THE PERMIT IT'S THE
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL COMMERCIAL
FOR SORT OF WHAT I'M SAYING IS
YOU'RE ANTICIPATING A BIG BAG.
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE IT'S
CERTAINLY GOING TO HAVE TO
RESPOND TO THIS ANYONE WHO IS
UNDER IT IS THAT CORRECT OR CAN
THE WATER BOARD SAY WELL WILL
CONCENTRATE ON THIS FIRST- THAT
FIRST OR- WHAT WHAT'S GOING ON.
I TO VISUALIZE IT THE FOR THE
REASON WE GAVE THE STATE BOARD
DISCUSSION IS SO THAT THEY CAN
DECIDE WHAT'S THE MOST
APPROPRIATE IF THERE IS A LARGE
GROUP OF FOLKS THAT ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FOLKS THAN THEY CAN
DIVIDE THE FIND THE PERMIT TO.
OR THEY COULD DO A TIERED
APPROACH AND GET THE LARGEST
POLLUTERS IN THE GREATEST
FACILITIES FIRST AND THEN AND
TEAR IT UP- IT'S REALLY UP TO
SUPPORT THEY COULD GO THROUGH IT
YOU KNOW THIS IS A CRITICAL
DATA. DRAINAGE BASIN SO WILL DO
THIS ONE FIRST. THEY CAN DO THAT
CORRECT OKAY SO THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO SAY
EVERY FACILITY IN THE STATE. HAS
TO SUDDENLY HE- DO SOMETHING.
WELL IT'S A STATE WIDE PERMIT
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO ASK IT
FROM EVERYONE. THE STATEWIDE
PERMIT FORM. WHAT DATE THEY
COULD CONCENTRATE ON PARTICULAR
DRAINAGE BASINS WHICH WOULDN'T
SURPRISE ME THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN LA CORRECT AND I MEAN
AND THAT'S WHY WE TRY TO KEEP IT
HIGH LEVEL IN KNOTS TIED THE
WATER BOARD'S HAND WE WANTED
THEM TO DISCUSSION TO HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. SO WHAT ADDITIONAL
SO IF THIS BILL PASSES WHAT
ADDITIONAL. EITHER POWER OR- A
REQUIREMENT GOES ON TO THE WATER
BOARD ARE THESE THINGS THAT THEY
COULDN'T DO WITHOUT THIS BILL OR
THE FACING THINGS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE FORCED TO DO WITH
THIS BILL. SO THEY HAVE THE
WATER BOARD HAVE THE AUTHORITY
UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT THAT
IF THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S A SET THAT UP FACILITY
CAUSES A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION OF POLLUTION. THE
COURT NOW SAYS THEY HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED THROUGH A PERMIT AND
THAT'S THE SECTIONS WE REFERENCE
IN THE LEGISLATION. AND FROM
THERE THE- THAT'S ESSENTIALLY IT
IN THE STATE WOULD CREATE THE
PERMIT- THE AND THE PERMIT WOULD
LIKELY HAVE. THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MONITORING THAT WOULD ONLY OCCUR
IF THEY PICK THE ONE OPTION OF
COMPYING WITH THEIR WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS ON SITE- IT
JUST DEPENDS ON HOW THEY-
DETERMINE THE PERMIT BUT THE
WATER BOARD'S THEMSELVES
WOULDN'T BE RESTRICTED IN ANY
WAY. YOU KNOW THERE ARE FORTY
DOESN'T CHANGE IN ANY WAY THIS
REALLY IS TRYING TO SET A
PRIORITY OF. THESE ARE VERY
LARGE CONTRIBUTING- STORMWATER
POLLUTANT POLLUTERS AND YET
RIGHT NOW THERE UNADDRESSED AND
SO REALLY IT'S SETTING A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO ADDRESS THAT OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD NOW HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS. AND YOU'RE
GOING TO REQUIRE THEM TO DO IT.
THAT'S CORRECT. YEAH I THINK
THAT'S FAIR OKAY. SO GIVEN AND I
KNOW THE PEOPLE ON THE STATE
WATER BOARD THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE PURITY OF OUR WATER
WHY AREN'T THEY DOING IT NOW. I
THINK IT'S SO WHEN THIS FIRST
CAME UP SO WE PETITIONED THE EPA
MOM AND I WORK IN THE REASONS
WHY BUT WE WERE GOING TO THE EPA
NOT THE STATE WATER BOARD TO DO
THIS THE EPA AGREED WITH OUR
POSITION THAT THESE WERE LARGE
CONTRIBUTORS OF POLLUTION BUT
THEY DECIDED NOT TO GIVE A
PERMIT BECAUSE THEY FELT THEY
WERE THE MUNICIPAL PERMIT QUITE
FRANKLY WOULD BE THE ONE TO
HANDLE IT. AND THAT'S WHEN WE
DID THE COURT CASE AND THE JUDGE
SAID NO IF YOU DO FIND THEIR
LARGE CONTRIBUTORS YOU HAVE TO
GIVE THEM A PERMIT AND SO WE'VE
BEEN CHUBB JUST STARTING WITH
LOS ANGELES ALMOST AS A TEST
CASES TO SEE HOW IT WORKS BUT
AGAIN WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE
STATEWIDE IN EVERY REGION THAT
THESE ARE LARGE CONTRIBUTORS AND
SO. IN FACT THIS REPORT MADE A
JOKE ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN
THIS FIRST HAPPENED AND THEY
SAID- YOU KNOW WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA HAVE TO DO A STATEWIDE
ORDER BECAUSE NGOS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PETITION BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE EVIDENCE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM WE DON'T
WANT TO PETITION EVERY REGIONAL
BOARD TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
AND DO A MALL INDIVIDUALLY WE
FEEL LIKE THIS IS A MORE
RESPONSIBLE AND LAID OUT
APPROACH EVEN IF WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE- YOU KNOW EVERY BIT OF
IT TO FIND IN THE LEAD. THIS THE
SATURDAY SO I AM GIVING A BETTER
FEELING FOR WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
SO THE FACT THAT THE CHAMBER
DOESN'T LIKE FAT PEOPLE CAN SUE
THEY'RE SUING ALREADY AND THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE ABILITY TO CALL
AHEAD IF I COULD JUST RESPOND
BRIEFLY TO THAT I THINK THE KEY
DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT- UNDER
THE PETITION PROCESS THAT SEAN
HAS OUTLINED YOU ARE SUING THE
REGIONAL OR STATE WATER BOARD
YOU'RE NOT SUING BY AN
INDIVIDUAL. COMPANY OR PROPERTY
OWNER. I YOU'RE SUING THE WATER.
CORRECT I'M- AND I GUESS JUST TO
PUT. IT DISCUSS THIS A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER- I JUST LIKE TO YOU
KNOW REITERATE OUR POSITION IS
THAT YOU KNOW THE STATE WATER
BOARD COULD- MAKE THIS PERMIT IF
IT. OR WANTED TO AND- THE- YOU
KNOW THAT MIGHT BE THE BETTER
FORUM FOR US TO TALK ABOUT A LOT
OF THESE ISSUES. AND WE- ARE
OPPOSED TO KIND OF. DETERMINING
WHICH PRIORITIES WHERE THE-
WATER BOARD PUTS THEIR ENERGY
AND THEIR LIMITED STAFF TIME.
ESPECIALLY AS OTHER COMMENTERS
MENTIONED THERE. COMING UP ON-
YOU KNOW RE ISSUANCE OF EXISTING
PERMITS SUCH AS THE INDUSTRIAL.
AND CONSTRUCTION STORMWATER
PERMITS. OKAY DO YOU AGREE WITH
WHAT SHE SAID. TO A POINT SHE'S
RIGHT THAT OF WHAT WE WERE JUST
DISCUSSING THE PETITIONS WERE TO
THE WATER AGENCIES THEMSELVES
NOT A PRIVATE- INDUSTRY. THIS
PERMIT IF WHEN IT GETS A DOCTOR
WHEN HE GOES FOR IT IS GOING TO
BE VERY SIMILAR TO THE
INDUSTRIAL STORMWATER PERMIT
THAT WAS REFERENCED. I WILL SAY
THAT THE LET ME ADJUST THE
TIMING. OF THIS YEAR THEY'RE
ADJUSTING TO THE STATEWIDE
PERMITS NEXT YEAR THEY'RE
PLANNING ON ADDRESSING THE
INDUSTRIAL PERMIT SO THAT SHOULD
BE DONE BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
CERTAINLY BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND IF WE NEED TO WORK WITH SOME
OF THE FOLKS THAT SPOKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PERMITS GET DONE
FIRST THAT'S MY PRIORITY TO LIKE
WHAT I THINK WE'RE ALL WANT
THOSE TO GET DONE FIRST AND SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO. TO MAKE LANGUAGE
CHANGES- FOR THAT AS FOR THE
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL LAWSUITS.
THERE ISN'T NECESSARILY IT THE
PARENT NEEDS TO BE AN NPDES
PERMIT UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT
AND THE CLEAN MARK DOES PROVIDE
FOR CITIZENS WHO PROVISIONS. BUT
THE REASON WE LIKE THIS THIS
THIS THE WAY THIS DIRECTION OF
THE WELL IT WAS THE LOS ANGELES
PERMIT IS GOING IS AGAIN THERE'S
THREE COMPLIANCE OPTIONS.
THERE'S THE OPTION ONE WHICH IS
MEET WATER QUALITY STANDARDS AT
THE END OF YOUR PROPERTY. THAT
IS THE SCENARIO WHERE IF THEY
WEREN'T MEETING THE STANDARDS
YES THIS IS A GROUP LIKE MINE
COULD BRING AN ENFORCEMENT
ACTION BUT WE'RE PROVIDING. OR
THE LOS ANGELES ONE IS PROVIDING
HAPPY TO PUT IT IN IF IT'S NOT
SO BUT THE OTHER TWO OPTIONS
WHICH- ALL YOU YOU DO IT AND
THERE'S NO SENSE IN PRIVATE
THERE'S NO SENSE IN ENFORCEMENT
AND THAT IS EITHER BUILDING
STORM WATER CAPTURE ON YOUR
PROPERTY AS DISCUSSED AT THE
BEGINNING. OR PAYING INTO THE
MUNICIPAL FUND AND ONCE YOU DO
THAT YOU'RE IN COMPLIANCE THERE
IS NO SAID SOME CHECKPOINTS. WE
HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST FOR FIVE ACRE PARKING LOT
TO. HOW MUCH THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GIVE OVER. I'M NOT AN
ENGINEER SO OB WE- I DON'T HAVE
THAT NUMBER IS A BIT MILLIONS OR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OR TENS OF
THOUSANDS. AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW
DON'T ANSWER IT'S NOT IN THE
MILLIONS PER PER FACILITY
CERTAINLY. IT'S MORE IN THAT THE
THOUSANDS- AND IT THE IDEA WOULD
BE SIMILAR TO WHAT'S IN SO THIS
WAS REFERENCED EARLIER. ON IN
PERMITS RIGHT NOW IF YOU DO
DEVELOPMENT OR REDEVELOPMENT-
YOU HAVE TO BUILD A STORMWATER
CAPTURE PROJECTS UP TO THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE STORM I
WILL GET INTO ALL THAT YEAH
YEAH. BUT THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN HERE EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE SO IT'S
ESSENTIALLY- IF IT WAS A
REDEVELOPMENT OR DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT IT'S THE SAME SIZE
CAPTURE. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD. I
HAVE A BETTER IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW THANK YOU-
MISTER RIVAS. YOU CAN TAKE AS
LONG AS YOU WANT TO CLOSE
RESPECT BASS WHEN I VOTE MR WORK
I HAVE- YOU KNOW I'VE
APPRECIATED ALL THE ENGAGEMENT
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH STEPS ARE
VERY CLOSE TO THE GERMAN
COMMERCE OF EXPECTED NUMBER
THEIR MOMENTS WE ARE WAITING FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE FROM
THEM- AND AS ALWAYS WE WILL
ENGAGE- ANY AND ALL. BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO GET IT RIGHT-
WE WANT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
YEAH THANK YOU DR WORK ALL RIGHT
SO WE EARLIER THIS YEAR WE HELD-
FORUM. OKAY WAS IT LAST YEAR AT
THE FARM ON PLASTIC. JAAP
PLASTIC GOING INTO THE- LOCAL-
A. WATERS OCEAN WATERS IT CETERA
THAT'S ONE TYPE OF POLLUTION AND
OIL AND SUCH IS PROBABLY THE
NEXT TYPE OF POLLUTION WERE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT. I
DO THINK WE HAVE TO FIND A
SOLUTION I DO THINK THAT HAVING
THE STATE WIDE APPROACH TO THE
PERMITTING DOES MAKE SENSE- I
THINK THE BIG QUESTION IS WHEN
THIS IS OUT THERE JUST HOW MUCH
OF A BURDEN IT'S GOING TO BE ON
THE STATE AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THE QUESTION WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE AN ANSWER TO. OUR
BOT- THAT IS THE SORT OF
QUESTION THAT THEY THEY LOOK AT
IN APPROPRIATIONS IT'S NOT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
COMMITTEE. RESPONSIBILITY OF
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO SAY DOES
THIS MAKE SENSE FROM A CLEAN
WATER POINT OF VIEW. THE DOLLARS
. THAT ENDED I MEAN THE STATE
HAS AN AWFUL LOT OF PARKING LOT
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO PAY A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IF IT'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO DO THIS SO
THAT IS GOING TO BE LOOKED AT AS
WELL AS DO WE NEED TO REIMBURSE
LOCAL CITIES AT CETERA SO I
THINK THAT'S MORE OF A MATTER
FOR APPROPRIATIONS I THINK THE
VOTE I'M ASKING FOR HERE IS DO
WE REALLY WANT TO CLEAN UP
STORMWATER. THIS SEEMS TO BE THE
RIGHT TIME AND THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO DO IT SO I'M GOING
TO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND- BUT
- WE CLEARLY WE NEED TO GET MORE
DEFINITION BEFORE IT GETS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS AND ON TO
THE FLOOR IN TERMS OF COST I
THINK THAT IS CHAMBERS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND I THINK
THEY SHOULD BE AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO
AND YOU'RE TELLING ME WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE A BETTER IDEA IN
THE COMING WEEKS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN LA SO I'M PREPARED
TO- ASK THAT WE BRING THIS ON TO
THE NEXT TO A COMMITTEE WHICH IS
APPROPRIATIONS. HAVING SAID THAT
THIS WILL BE A DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY.
YEAH DID WE GET A- NUMBER OF ALL
RIGHT MISTER MAYOR CG WE HAVE A
SECOND YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA SECRETARY MEMBER GARCIA
OKAY. VERY GOOD THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
ROBERT RIVAS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CORK
HIGH COURT I SMITH NO SMITH NO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I OUR QUE HAN
ARE QUE HAND I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING
MURATSUCHI WHAT I TO GI WALDRON
. WE HAVE AN APPROACH THAT TO
PASS OKAY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR REALLY GETTING
INTO THIS BILL. ONE THAT. TO MY
MIND IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN DO. AND-
THERE'S- I TRUST MR RIVAS WILL
LA AND MISTER BOSWELL WILL- DO A
GREAT JOB GETTING THIS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS DOWN TO THE FLOOR
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
MISTER REAVIS YOU'RE NOT SURE L.
MISTER CHAIR KANAI. YEAH I MEAN
THE COMMITTEES BEEN. INVOKED A
COUPLE OF TIMES AND I JUST I
VOTED FOR IT BUT WE RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO. AS THE CHAIR HAD
OUTLINED AS THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
MOOSE'S JURISDICTION WILL LOOK
AT IT THROUGH A DIFFERENT SENSE
OF OURS YEAH WE REALLY DO NEED
TO LOOK AT THE COST AND I'M
HOPING WE WILL. GET THAT THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SENATE THAT'S FOR
ME TO. OKAY. YES SO THAT TRUE
LOS YES MISTER WAS CHAIR OF A
PROBE I PUT LOT OF HE HAS A LOT
OF WORK TO DO. AND HE WHAT HE
SAID IS A YES VOTE HERE ISN'T
THE SAME AS A YES VOTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT BEING ON
APPROPRIATIONS MYSELF. AND I
WILL CERTAINLY LISTEN TO WHAT MR
HOLDEN TELLS ME. ALL RIGHT- CHAU
TWENTY ONE OH WAIT MISTER
REAVIS- WATER POLICY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
DISADVANTAGED AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION ARE YOU
MISS BASS YOU CAN BE TESTIFYING
AGAIN I GUESS I AM THEN JUST A
FAIR OKAY. AND THERE'S ROOM
THERE'S ROOM FOR MORE. WHITE WHY
GET UP AND DOWN WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO. THANKS AGAIN- THE STAFF
FOR THE ANALYSIS- DOCTOR QUICK
APPRECIATE UP 280% THIS BILL
IT'S ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE ZERO
EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO ELEVATE THE
VOICES. OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
WATER POLICY DECISIONS BY
DESIGNATING ONE SEAT ON THE
STATE AND REGIONAL WATER BOARDS
TO BE FILLED BY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE OR A TRIBAL COMMUNITY
MEMBER. SUCH A STATION ALSO
SEEKS TO INCORPORATE ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE ANALYSIS INTO THE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR MAJOR WATER
PERMITS YOU KNOW THIS YEAR AS I
MENTIONED- HOW DO. YOU KNOW IN
THE- IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM MARKS
THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
PASSAGE OF THE FEDERAL CLEAN
WATER ACT AND ON THIS FIFTIETH
YEAR ANNIVERSARY MANY LOW INCOME
HOUSING COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
STILL LACK ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
. MANY OF THESE UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER RESOURCE DOESN'T
COMMUNITIES. ARE HOME TO LOW
INCOME WORKERS WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO LACK RESOURCES A
LACK THE TIME. AND LIKE THE
ACCESS TO ADVOCATE AGAINST
POLICIES THAT HARM THEIR
COMMUNITIES RESULTING IN IN AT
SOME DECADES OF NEGLECT.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO SEATS
RESERVED FOR A MEMBER FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE OR A
TRIBAL- A COMMUNITY BACKGROUND
ON OUR STATE AND REGIONAL WATER
BOARDS. AND WHILE THE CURRENT
BOARD HAS TAKEN SOME PROACTIVE
STEPS TO IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT
JUSTICE OUTCOMES- WE MUST ENSURE
THAT OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE MOVING FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD REQUIRE COMMUNITY OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT I AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE POLICY
SOME CONSIDERATIONS FOR MAJOR
WATER PERMITS BUT THE STATE
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS ISSUE
THERE WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
ARE- AERIAL ASSAULT THE BAR- ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER.
CENTER ALSO- HERE TESTIFY IS
CAITLYN SIS ON BEHALF OF THE-
WEINMAN. A WINDOW TRY. THANK YOU
MR. RIGHT WHO WILL SPEAK FIRST
THEN. TICKETS ARE CHECKED OF
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LYDIA
SULLIVAN AND I'M WITH THE
COMMITTEE WATER CENTER WHO IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
ZERO EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PREVIOUS BOB THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A CRITICAL TOOL FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE. NINE WATER INEQUITIES
SPECIFICALLY BY ENSURING THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE DURING
CRITICAL WATER POLICY DECISIONS.
AND ENSURING THAT MAY INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ANALYSIS-
WITH IN THOSE DECISIONS BOTH OF
THESE WILL FURTHER THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO THE CORRECT WATER
WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO.
DO STILL IN FACT A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER WHEN THEY
OPEN THE TAP. NOW THE STATE
WATER BOARD WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AND TO THE
BEST OF OUR KNOWLEDGE. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WAS ACTUALLY THE FIRST
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD WITH A BACKGROUND IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE- THAT
MEMBER WAS LARA FIRESTONE.
COFOUNDER OF THE CLEAN WATER
CENTER WHO WAS APPOINTED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. MEANING THAT
AFTER FIFTY TWO YEARS THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
FINALLY HAD- AND THAT. THAT'S
THE DECISION MAKER ON THE STATE
WATER BOARD WITH A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD FOR ADVOCATE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AB TWENTY
ONE ZERO EIGHT ENSURES THAT TYPE
OF REPRESENTATION REMAINS AND I
FUTURE GOVERNORS ALSO PROVIDE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION AT THE STATE
WATER BOARD AND THE REGIONAL
FORCE BECAUSE THEIR DECISIONS
IMPACT. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE MOST IT'S ALSO
POINTED OUT THE AB TWENTY ONE
ZERO EIGHT DOES NOT REPLACE ANY
OF THE EXISTING WATER BOARD
SEATS. AND THAT THE BILL'S
LANGUAGE IS ACTUALLY DENTICLE TO
EXISTING THATCHER RELATING TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD REQUIRING
ONE MEMBER TO BE A- QUALIFIED
REPRESENTATIVE FROM AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS- IF AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS K. GUARANTEED
REPRESENTATION AT THE STATE
WATER BOARD FOR THEIR DECISIONS
WHY SHOULD THE COMMUNITY. THAT
ARE MOST DEEPLY IMPACTED BY
WATER POLLUTION HAVE EQUAL
REPRESENTATION FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD AND OUR NEXT
WITNESS- MISTER SISK- HE'S ON
THE PHONE OKAY MISTER CISCO
PLEASE- SPEAK UP. YEAH THANK YOU
CARE FOR ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY SAYS
AND I'M THE CHIEF AND SPIRITUAL
LEADER OF THE MINIMUM. I'VE BEEN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN OUR NAME
MEANS MIDDLE WATER PEOPLE. WATER
AND FAMILY ARE AT THE CENTER OF
OUR HISTORY AND OUR CULTURE AND
OUR RELIGION. I HEARD YOU DO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT
ONE. OUR TRIBE. OUR TRIBE'S
CULTURE IS THREATENED BY POOR
WATER MANAGEMENT STATE REGIONAL
WATER BOARD DECISIONS ABOUT
TEMPERATURE. MANAGEMENT WATER
RIGHTS WATER FLOWS AND WATER
QUALITY HAVE BEEN BIG. I'VE BEEN
A BIG IMPACT ON OUR PEOPLE AND
OUR SALMON. AB TWENTY ONE. WOULD
DO THREE THINGS. IT WOULD GIVE
ALL TRIBES. FEDERAL RECOGNIZE
YOU'RE NOT REPRESENTATION. BY
REQUIRING AT LEAST ONE MEMBER.
OF THE STATE MORE REGIONAL WATER
BOARDS TO HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH
OUR TRAVEL ISSUES. IT WOULD FIRE
STATE AND EGIONAL WATER BOARDS
TO GIVE ALL OUTRAGE THEY BOYS
AND REMOVE BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
US FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE
DECISION THAT AFFECT. PROVIDE
MORE OPENNESS AND AN ANALYSIS TO
DECISION MAKERS AND DECISIONS
THAT AFFECT. US IN THE FUTURE
TRAVEL GENERATION THAN VILLAGES
. TODAY STATE LAW REQUIRES IN
THE WATER ENGINEERS WATER RIGHT
. EXPERT THE AGRICULTURE TO BE
REPRESENTED ON THE WATER BOARD
FOR DECADES THAT HAS MEANT THAT
THE POLLUTERS ARE GUARANTEED TO
VOTE ON STATE WATER BOARD BUT
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND TRIBES ARE MOST AFFECTED BY
WATER BOARD DECISIONS ARE NOT
GUARANTEED A VOTE CURRENTLY
TRIBES THERE MOST UNDER
REPRESENTED IN STATE WATER
DECISION. GOVERNOR NATHAN HAS
PLEDGED TO CHANGE CALIFORNIA'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH CALIFORNIANS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT SHOWS HOW
- TO DO THAT IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
. FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE WATER
BOARD CUT BACK OF THE 20% BETTER
THAN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT-
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES ARE ALREADY
AT BARE MINIMUM WATER USE
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE LONG BEEN
HELLO ALL OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. 20%
BACK YUP WE'VE GONE OVER THE
FOUR MINUTES OCT IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE. YES I DO WANT YOU TO
. CONSIDER THE BILL AND VOTE FOR
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
. ALL RIGHT- NEXT I'M GOING TO
ASK FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WHICH IS MISS BASS
AGAIN. RIGHT I THINK THERE'S
ANOTHER PRIMARY WITNESS AND
OBSERVATION AS WELL SO YEAH
ALMOST BASS HE VERY TIME ARE
GOING TO BE THE TIMELY WILL ALSO
HEAR FROM ROBERT READ THAT LAST
FOR SOME REASON YOU WANT HIM TO
GO FIRST. I'M I CAN GO FIRST I
GUESS SINCE I'M UP HERE AND
THEN- GET OUT OF YOUR HAIR. SIX
OF GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN THANK
YOU. SURE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AGAIN I AM GOING TO
PASS ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND- WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
ONE OH EIGHT UNLESS AMENDED- BUT
WE ARE STILL EVALUATING SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT CAME IN
AFTER OUR LETTER WAS SUBMITTED
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
FURTHER COULDN'T THAT
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS BILL. AND
THIS BILL HAS MANY PROVISIONS
THAT ARE SO I'M JUST GOING TO
KIND OF HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
OUR MAIN CONCERNS AND I WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT THE COMING OUT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD
ADOPTED A RESOLUTION I NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT COMMITTED
THE BOARD TO CAREFULLY
CONSIDERING IMPACTS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SO
THIS IN CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER
EXISTING LAWS THAT REQUIRE
PUBLIC NOTICE AND PARTICIPATION
OPPORTUNITIES MAKE MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL IN OUR
VIEW- I NECESSARY OF THE BILL
ALSO WOULD IMPOSE. NEW COSTS
THAT WE THINK ARE LIKELY TO BE
BORNE BY REGULATED ENTITIES IN
THE FORM OF INCREASED PERMIT
FEES SO AS WE HEARD THE BILL
IMPOSES NEW ANALYSIS AND
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS- IN THE
WATER BOARD'S PLANNING AND
PERMITTING PROCESSES AND OUT
SPECIFICALLY IN GEN THREE OF THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT THE WATER
BOARD'S CONSIDERING MITIGATING-
INTERMODAL JUSTICE IMPACTS EARLY
IN THE PROJECT PLANNING PROCESS
SEES WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE WHICH
PROJECTS THIS WOULD APPLY TO.
THE WORLD AND SIR BUT THIS
CREATE OVERLAP SEE WHAT IN TERMS
OF ANALYSIS AND MITIGATION AND
THAT MEANS THAT FOR PROJECTS
THAT OTHERWISE SUBJECT TO SEE
WHAT- IT ADDED TO GET STAFF IT
ATTENTION SO WHAT I'M PROJECT.
EIGHT BEST TENSION. IS KNOW ARE
SERIOUS IMPACTS WITH A WHITE. I
IN THE RECENT YOU SEE BURKE.
CASE OVER THE SECTION FOR THE
CREATE POSITIONS WITHIN THE
WATER. AND EAST IN PRO FOR. I'M
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES PARTICIPATE
FOR THE Y. BOARD'S AND WE'RE NOT
SURE HOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
PAID FOR- AND WE THINK A PERSON
THE RED THAT PERMIT FEES WILL BE
INCREASED TO COVER THE NEW
PROGRAM AND STAFF POSITIONS.
WHICH ULTIMATELY CAN RESULT IN
THE PERMITS HE THEN ARE RAISING
RATES TO COVER COSTS WHICH OF
COURSE THEN TRICKLES DOWN TO THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN IN THE TERMS
OF. OUR INCREASED COSTS FOR
WATER WASTEWATER WHAT HAVE YOU-
WE ALSO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD RESTRICT THE GOVERNOR'S
ABILITY TO APPOINT PERSONS TO
SERVE ON THE STATE AND I
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS AND I DID
WANT TO NOTE. THAT THERE ARE NO
AG STEEP SET ASIDES ON THE NINE
AND REGIONAL WATER BOARDS- SO
THIS TIME WE MUST RETAIN OUR-
PROPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME FOR THIS.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CLEAR PRESENTATION AND YOUR
CONCERNS- MYSTERY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CLIENT ELSE
FOR THE DELETION OF PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL THAT MANDATE THE
APPOINTMENT OF PERSONS WHO HAVE
A PROVEN HISTORY. OF ADVOCATING
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
JUSTICE FOR TRAVEL RIGHTS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THIS
ADVOCACY ROLES IN CONSISTENT
WITH STATE LAW ON POLICIES.
RELATING TO WATER RIGHTS AND
WATER QUALITY. SINCE ITS
CREATION IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
STATE BOARD HAS FILED ITS
ORIGINAL MANDATE TO BALANCE. TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE ALL USES OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER RESOURCES
INTO ENSURE THE REASONABLE
PROTECTION A BENEFICIAL USES IN
THE PREVENTION OF NUISANCE.
STATE POLICY PROVIDES THAT THE
GRANTING OF WATER RIGHTS IN THE
DISPOSAL OF WASTES INTO THE
WATERS OF THE STATE. SHALL BE
REGULATED ACHIEVE THE HIGHEST
WATER QUALITY CONSISTENT WITH
MAXIMUM BENEFIT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE IN OTHER WORDS THE
STATE BOARD HAS A DUTY TO
REPRESENT THE BEST INTERESTS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. SECOND THERE
ARE MULTIPLE LAWS REGULATIONS
AND POLICIES THAT ENSURE THAT
THE NEEDS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE MET BY THE
ENTIRE STATE BOARD. AS WELL AS
THE REGIONAL BOARD. CALIFORNIA
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER LAWS BEEN
MENTIONED AS ONE. THE SAFER
PROGRAM IS ANOTHER WHICH FLOWED
OUT OF SB TWO HUNDRED BY FORMER
SENATORS- BILL MONEY IN- THAT-
IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS WHO LACK SAFE
ADEQUATE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER RECEIVE IT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. SAFER ACCORDING TO THE
STATE BOARD AND I QUOTE
MINIMIZES THE DISPROPORTIONATE
ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS
EXPERIENCED BY SOME COMMUNITIES
ADVANCES JUSTICE FOR PEOPLE OF
ALL INCOMES RACES AND CULTURES.
BOTH THE DRINKING WATER AND
CLEAN WATER INTENDED USE PLANS
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT CONTINUE TO STRESS HELPING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SOLVE
THEIR DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS
PRIORITIZE SEPTIC TO SEWER
CONVERSIONS. AND FURTHER SPECIFY
THAT UP 210% OF AVAILABLE FUNDS
MAY BE UTILIZED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND CAPACITY BUILDING
AND DAX. FINALLY IT'S STATE
WATER BOARD RESOLUTION WHICH AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY STATES THAT
THE SHARED MISSION OF THE BOARD
THE NINE REGIONAL BOARDS IS TO
PRESERVE ENHANCE AND RESTORE THE
QUALITY OF CALIFORNIA'S. WATER
RESOURCES AND DRINKING WATER FOR
THE PROTECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALL BENEFICIAL USES. AND TO
ENSURE PROPER WATER RESOURCE
ALLOCATION AND FISHING USE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF PRESENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS. RELATIONS
MISSION THE WATER BOARDS HAVE
ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CONFRONTING STRUCTURAL
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM- YOUR WAY
OVER COULD YOU- FORTUNATELY I
WAS DISTRACTED- COULD YOU JUST
SOMEBODY SEVERAL ALSO IF YOU'RE
AT LIBERTY TO TELL US WHO YOUR
CLIENT IS GET THE VALLEY ATWATER
COALITION WE'VE- COMMUNICATE
WITH COMMITTEE I'M SORRY. WITH
TWO MINUTES I TRY NOT TO TAKE UP
TIME THAT SOMETHING LIKE THAT
YOU CAN JUST SUMMARIZING YOUR SO
IN CLOSING- YOU KNOW THE WORK OF
THE STATE BOARD IS NOT TO- TO
DETERMINE WINNERS OR LOSERS AND
THEIR DECISIONS AND THEIR ORDERS
ARE. VERY CHALLENGING AND QUITE
OFTEN- DON'T MEET WITH THE
SATISFACTION OF ANY OF THE
PARTIES. WE THINK THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE THAT EVEN. WORSE IN
TERMS OF THE WORK OF THE STATE
BOARD WITH GROUP RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE ABSENT THE
AMENDMENT THAT THE CLIENT SIX
THANK YOU SIR. OKAY OTHERS IN
THE ROOM FIRST WHO WOULD- SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. HELLO AGAIN MY NAME
IS CODY PHILLIPS- AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS THE MONO THEY
COMMITTEE- THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE- A DIRECTING
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND THEN ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WAS SUPPOSED. SKAPSKI THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR DON KHAKI ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE AND STEVE IS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES.
AND WE'LL HEAR FROM ANYONE WHO
IS EITHER OPPOSED OR IN FAVOUR.
AND PLEASE JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. MR OPERATOR. AND WE'LL START WITH ONE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON PAN LOPEZ WITH
KEITH STREET CONSULTING ON
BEHALF OF THE TALK SHE TRIED IN
SUPPORT. THE NEXT ONE SIXTY FIVE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUDY HUGHES IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF THE PROJECT PRODUCER'S
REPRESENTATIVE PROFIT IN A
CALIFORNIA- IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. TO MOVE ON THE LINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF ANNUALLY ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. WE GO TO ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS ARE BACK
ABOUT INVOLVED BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON
GENERATION GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WESTERN PLANT HEALTH ASSOCIATION
AND WESTERN AGRICULTURAL
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME SHARE. RIGHT THEN
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS THANK YOU
GO AHEAD I JUST HAVE ONE M.
QUICK COMMENT AND HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE AUTHOR WHICH IS- THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS YOU KNOW SINCE
TAKING ON THE CHAIR OF WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SOCIALLY
WITH OUR NATIVE PEOPLE AND HOW
LEFT OUT THERE ARE FROM THE
CONVERSATIONS BUT THAT'S TRUE
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
WELL SO I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK ONE THING I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IN THE BILL IS
THAT. YOU RECOMMEND THAT THE
WATER BOARD USE CALAVERAS GREEN
TO ADVERTISE COMMUNITIES AS I
THINK YOU KNOW IT'S NEVER THE
BAY AREA CAUCUS IT IS A
CALCULATION THAT OFTEN LEAVES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
BAY AREA OUT AND SO I HOPE WE
CAN LOOK AT THAT PIECE TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LEFT BEHIND WILL BE INCLUDED
AS WELL THANK YOU. FOR THE
SUGGESTION YEAH ABSOLUTELY. JOHN
I'LL JUST ADD CALLIN VIRUS BRAIN
LOOKS AT ERIC. THIS IS A WATER
ISSUE. SO I DON'T THINK KALAN
VIRUS GREEN IS APPROPRIATE I
THINK THAT'S A- GOOD POINT. MISS
BARRICADE AND- ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT. ALRIGHT
LEVINE SECONDED- SO WE STILL
HAVE. YOU STILL HAVE QUESTIONS
AS TO HOW THIS WOULD BE FUNDED I
WOULD BE VERY SURPRISED IF IT'S
ANYTHING OTHER THAN- PERMIT HE'S
HAVING TO DO IT I DON'T SEE IT
COMING FROM THE GENERAL FUND SO
I THINK. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
PREPARATIONS WILL HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. HE AND THEN THIS IS THE
WATER QUALITY COMMITTEE THE
WATER QUANTITY COMMITTEE CHAIRS
RIGHT OVER HERE MISS POWER K.
HAND SHE SHE WILL BE LOOKING
IT'S JUST BEEN REFERRED TO HER
COMMITTEE AS WELL SO- YOU'RE
YOU'RE GONNA GET- HOW CAN I SAY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES. OF FROM
A THE SAME MEMBERS WHO MAY VOTE
YES HERE BUT MAY HAVE OTHER
RESERVATIONS IN THEIR OWN
COMMITTEES. SO AGAIN FROM A
WATER QUALITY POINT OF VIEW I
DON'T THINK ANYONE IS HERE IS
PROPOSING TO SAY THAT TRIBES-
HAVEN'T BEEN NEGLECTED I KNOW
THAT. THE OPPOSITION WAS SAYING
WELL THIS IS REQUIRED ALREADY. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S EVIDENCE
THAT- COMMUNITIES ARE LOW INCOME
AND- TRAVEL COMMUNITIES BEEN
TREATED FAIRLY. SO I DO THINK.
TEST TEST TEST TEST TEST. NO
FEEDBACK
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHANG. NO I
KNOW THAT THE- SO THIS IS.
PERHAPS I DON'T. AM LOOKING FOR
Y. OKAY SO THIS IS PRODUCT
SAFETY TEXTILES AND PROFESS ONE
OF YOUR FAVORITE TOPICS BE FAST. SO WE HAVE- MY PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WHICH ARE
IN THE ANALYSIS IN THE BEEN
PASSED AROUND TO MEMBERS AND
LEDGE COUNCIL FORM. WHETHER
BEING PASSED NOW. BUT THESE
MEMBERS WILL COLOR FIGHT
EXEMPTIONS TO THE P. FAST
PROHIBITIONS IN THE BILL. THE
FIRST IS FOR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. AND THE SECOND IS FOR
AFTERMARKET TREATMENTS FOR
TEXTILES BECAUSE THOSE PRODUCTS
ARE CURRENTLY REGULATED UNDER
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL. OUT
YOU CHECK THESE AMENDMENTS
ABSOLUTELY I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS ALL RIGHT YOU MAY
START TO PRESENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WHEN IT'S WORKING
WONDERFUL- IN JUST SO YOU KNOW
WE GOT SIX VOTES FOR THE LAST
BILL MISTER REDUCES. TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN. WHAT WONDERFUL SO AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN IS THE SAFER
CLOTHES AND TEXTILES ACT IT
BUILDS UPON A NUMBER OF BILLS
I'VE CARRIED AROUND KEY FAST
OVER THE LAST. FEW YEARS A. B.
AT EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN- WOULD BAN
THE SALE OF TEXTILES THAT
CONTAIN P. FAST BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOR THE BILL'S GOING TO PHASE
OUT P. FAST IN THE VAST MAJORITY
OF TEXTILE APPLICATIONS- BUT
GIVEN THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCT
PROGRAMS WORK IT'LL EXCLUDE
CARPETS. RUGS AND AFTERMARKET
TREATMENT THAT ALSO MAKE
EXCEPTIONS FOR PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT USED IN
FIREFIGHTING- P. FAST AS WE KNOW
IN THIS COMMITTEE. IT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS FOREVER CHEMICAL GETS
INTO OUR WATER SYSTEM-
CURRENTLY. IF WE LOOK OUT OF OUT
OF TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
ACTIVE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE TESTED 65% HAPPY FAST THE
TICKET OF THEM WHICH IS A NUMBER
OF FILE WHICH SERVES ABOUT
SIXTEEN MILLION PEOPLE IN TOTAL.
AND IF YOU TALK TO A VARIETY OF
TEXTILE. MANUFACTURES READY MANY
COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY DECIDED
TO PHASE OUT OR WILL BE PHASING
OUT P. FAST. OF FOOTWEAR COMPANY
SKECHERS KEEN PUMA NIKE. VF
WHICH IS. THE PARENT BRAND FOR
NORTH FACE AND TIMBERLAND.
LEVI'S AND M. GAP. IN THE TAX
WHICH IS THE PARENT COMPANY OF
ZARA TO GET THAT RIGHT MR CARE.
JACK WILL SCAN FOLDER SKEWS ME-
JACK WILL SCAN POLITECNICA
PATAGONIA VF OSPREY DAUGHTER
DOUTOR SKEWS ME I KIA- AND
TARGET AND SO YOU CAN SEE. THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS ALREADY
STARTING TO LEAD THE WAY ON THIS
ISSUE KNOWING THAT WE WANT TO
KEEP UP P. FAST OUT OF FAR-
WATER STREET IN PARTICULAR- IN
TERMS OF CLOTHING IF YOU WASH
YOUR CLOTHING THAT HAS P. FAST
pAS WELL AS IF YOU WEAR P.
FASTENER RANGE YOU CAN GET INTO
THE WATER STREAM AS WELL SO
WITHOUT HAVE TO WITNESSES- ABI
KERR. SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH NRDC
AND DR LAURA CIDER WHO'S A
SENIOR RESEARCH SCIENTIST AT
FIVE AND SPRING BOTH ARE ON THE
PHONE. VERY GOOD- SHOW WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK FIRST DOCTOR SCHNEIDER.
FOR THE CARD FROM AN IT ON THAT
THE FIRST IS THAT CAN'T. GO
AHEAD. YEAH TO CHECK WORKING
MA'AM AND BACK BUT YEAH TO SPEAK
HI MY NAME IS ARGHA KAR ON THE
AND TRACK FOR HELP FOOD AND
NATIONAL DEFENSE GOT. AND I SEE
THAT BY. BOB ENTITY SEVENTEEN
THE BACK. TO PARDON THING MY
ACTION. THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOMEONE GOT. FIVE FROM THE BACK. HAVE YOU HEARD PEOPLE AFFECT.
THE MAN FRIENDS CHEMICAL THERE
ON IN BY. AND OUR THIRTY IN A
WITH NEARLY AND HEALTHCARE
INCLUDING CANCER CAN OR LIVER
DAMAGE AND INTERFERENCE WITH THE
- UPTAKE. CALVET HAS ALREADY ON
THE PRINCIPLE THAT THE FACT
SHOULD BE A LITTLE FROM TOP TO
HAVE A POP. HAPPY BY DONNAN
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED PACK.
FIREFIGHTING FOAM AND OTHER
PRODUCT. THAT THE RELIGION BE
INVITED PROP CONTAIN THEM CALLED
TAX. MANUFACTURE YOU TO CLEAN
AND- AS I WATER YOU CAN NOTED SO
REDUCTION OF PIZZA. IMPORTANT
STATE WATER CARS. AND HAVE YOU
HEARD CALIFORNIA WATERS WITH
SERVING A TO FIFTEEN MILLION.
HAVE ALREADY BEEN FOUND THE BEST
PENALTY I CLEAN UP DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE. CONTAMINATION BOTTOM
UP. AND DISADVANTAGED. HELLO
TECH THAN OTHERS WOULD BE IF THE
UNLESS YOU'VE PIZZA AND SHOULD
BE ELIMINATED FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY F PRODUCT THE BEST
THING IN WHAT WITH THE FUNCTION
ARE SIMPLY NOT THE GIVEN
POTENTIAL HARM. REPORTS THE
WASHINGTON STATE OF THE- AND
EUROPEAN UNION SHOW THAT THE ARE
MORE. MULTIPLE TO WATER THE-
INCLUDING THE- AND ALL DESIGN
AND ALL MATERIAL. STAY IN CAN
OFFER BE ADDRESS THE WATER. AND
OTHER FABRICS UP TO. INHERENTLY
AND CHECK OUT ADDITIONAL OP.
TWENTY SEVEN NOT NEEDED INFLOWS
AND OUR DEMOS. BY THE MANY DAYS
COMPANIES THAT HAVE ALL THE
DAILY. THAT CAN TO ELIMINATE
BEHALF INCLUDE BRANDS LIKE
LEVI'S GAP T. R. PAY I. AND
POPULAR IDEA GET A COPY PADDOCK
. IN THE PADDOCK FOR THE TELL.
THE TIME FOR A LAW THAT REQUIRE
ABOUT THE THREE THEY CAN UP. WE
HAVE THE AYE ABOUT EIGHTY
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD I
NEXT WILL HEAR FOR- LARA
SCHRADER FROM SOME SPRING. GO
AHEAD. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CHOIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THING
YOU FOR THE PROPER TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY I'M LAUREL SHADER AND
A SENIOR SCIENTIST AT SILENT
SPRING INSTITUTE WITH A PHD IN
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING FROM
UC BERKELEY SILENT SPRING IS AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION THAT INVESTIGATES
LINKS BETWEEN EVERYDAY CHEMICALS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH I CURRENTLY
LEAD THREE FEDERALLY FUNDED
STUDIES ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
TRANSPORT EXPOSURE AND HELP
PROTECT THE PIZZA. I'D LIKE TO
SHARE THREE KEY POINTS RELATED
TO BE FASTENED TEXTILE BASED ON
MY OWN RESEARCH AND OTHER
PUBLISHED RESEARCH STUDIES FIRST
THE FACT THAT ARE COMMON IN
TEXTILE BASED CONSUMER PRODUCTS
SILENT SPRING RECENTLY TESTED
FOR P. FAST IN NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED TEXTILE PRODUCTS
INCLUDING APPAREL BEDDING AND
FURNISHINGS WE SELECTED PRODUCTS
THE CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
HAVE FREQUENT CONTACT WITH SUCH
AS SCHOOL UNIFORMS AND
CHILDREN'S BEDDING. TOTAL
FOREIGN WHICH OF AN AND OF P.
FAST WAS DETECTED IN 65% OF
PRODUCTS MARKETED TO STAY IN OUR
WATER RESISTANT. EVEN STAIN AND
WATER RESISTANT PRODUCTS LABELED
AS GREEN ARE NONTOXIC HAD
DETECTABLE LEVELS OF PIZZA. OUR
FINDINGS UNDERSCORE THAT
INFORMATION ON PRODUCT LABEL
CANNOT BE USED BY CONSUMERS TO
IDENTIFY P. FAST THREE ITEMS.
SECOND TWO THOUSAND TEXTILE
POLLUTE OUR BODIES IN
ENVIRONMENT. HE FOUND DO NOT
REAL REMAINING PRODUCT THEY
MIGRATED TO INDOOR AIR AND
THAT'S WHERE WE CAN BREED THEM
AND- IN JAFFNA. THEY MAY COME
OFF ON OUR SKIN FROM DIRECT
CONTACT. DURING WASHING THEY CAN
END UP IN WASTE WATER. IN
OVERTIME THEY CAN BE RELEASED
FROM DISCARDED PRODUCTS AND END
UP IN LANDFILL LEACHATE. WITHOUT
HARM COMMUNITIES CLOSE TO
MANUFACTURING PLANTS AND
INCINERATORS THAT HANDLE P. FAST
WAYS. EXACERBATING ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE. AND FINALLY HE GOT
THERE NEED TO BE IN TEXTILES. IN
OUR STUDY 35% OF TEXTILES
LABELED AS WATER STAIN RESISTANT
DID NOT HAVE P. FAST.
DEMONSTRATING THAT ALTERNATIVES
ALREADY EXIST. I HOPE YOU TAKE
THE SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION INTO
ACCOUNT IF YOU CONSIDERWAYS TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY
NONESSENTIAL USES A PIZZA. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. AND. WE CAN NOW
HEAR FROM MA. ANYONE WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE SOME
PRIMARY WITNESSES I SEE TÌM HERE
WHAT YOU COME UP TO THE TABLE.
PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL. HE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME AS WELL
WAGNER OF ARNOLD AND PORTER AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF TEXTILE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ITS MEMBERS WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN. HE FASTER A GROUP OF
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS THAT
SHARE A COMMON CHARACTERISTIC A
STRONG BOND BETWEEN CARBON AND
FLUORINE ATOMS. CALLED ORGANIC
FLORIAN. HOWEVER THERE IS GREAT
BILL VARIABILITY ACROSS P. FAST
CHEMISTRY. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
PEOPLE ASK OUR SOLID SUMMER
LIQUID SUMMER GAS. IMPORTANTLY
THE EFFECTS ON HUMANS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT APPEAR TO VARY
SIGNIFICANTLY. SCIENTIFIC DATA
SUPPORT THAT SOME P. FAST MAY BE
TOXIC LIKE LEGACY LIKE THE
LEGACY COMPOUND PFOA. AND OTHER
NON POLYMERIC ACIDS. HOWEVER
SCIENTIFIC DATA DO NOT CURRENTLY
SUPPORT THAT TOXICITY ARE
BIOACCUMULATION OF OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED P. FAST UNDER THE
BROAD DEFINITION THIS BILL. LIKE
POLYMERIC ORGANIC FLOORING
COMPOUNDS. POLYMERIC P. FAST ARE
GENERALLY NOT WATER SOLUBLE NOR
MOBILE AND IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB
EXPLAINING NON POLYMERIC ACIDIC
P. FAST LIKE PFOA BUT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO ADDRESS OTHER LESS
CONCERNING CHEMISTRY LIKE THE
CHEMISTRY USED BY THE TEXTILE
INDUSTRY LARGELY IS BY THE
TEXTILE INDUSTRY. WHICH IS THE
POLYMERIC VARIATION. GIVEN THE
VARIABILITY IN P. FAST EVEN EPA
IS NOT PRESENTLY REGULATING P.
FAST AS A CLASS. A MORE NARROW
DEFINITION OF P. FAST WOULD
BETTER TRACK THE SCIENCE FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
LEGISATURE PASSED THE TOXIC
FREE COSMETICS ACT WHICH
PROHIBITED SPACE SPECIFIC
PROBLEMATIC BE FAST CHEMISTRY.
I'D RATHER THAN REGULATING AT ON
A CLASS WIDE BASIS. THE TEXTILE
INDUSTRY USES POLYMERIC ORGANIC
FLOORING THIS CHEMISTRY IS
ESSENTIAL AND INTRIGUING
TEXTILES AND MUST BE DURABLE
SUCH AS TEXTILES REPELLED OIL
AND WATER. INCLUDING OUTDOOR
FURNITURE HI TRAFFIC POULTRY
BUILDING COVERS AN AUTOMOBILE
USES THERE IS NO KNOWN VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE CHEMISTRY THAT WOULD
MEET THE DEMANDING PERFORMANCE
SPECIFICATION FOR SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS. IF THIS BILL PASSES IN
ITS CURRENT FORM PROHIBITING ALL
P. FASTEN TEXTILES IT IS AN
INDUSTRY KILLER. SPEAKING
GENERALLY TEXTILES HAVE A
RELATIVELY LOWER EXPOSURE
PROFILE COMPARED TO OTHER
PRODUCTS THEY'RE NOT WORN ON THE
BODY AND HOLD AND HUMAN CONTACT
WOULD BE INTERMITTENT. TEXTILES
ARE ALSO GENERALLY NOT CLEANED
IN A WASHING MACHINE. IF ALL P.
FASTER PROHIBITED AND TEXTILES
THE INDUSTRY WILL EITHER STOP
SELLING THESE QUALITY PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA OR OR THEY'LL BE
FORCED TO USE CHEMISTRY THAT
ISN'T A FACTOR. WHICH WILL CAUSE
SHORTER PRODUCT LIFE INCREASE
WASTE. ACCORDINGLY WE BELIEVE
THE DEFINITION OF TEXTILE
ARTICLES SHOULD BE NARROWED. IT
IS NOTICEABLE IT IS AVAILABLE
YOU'VE TAKEN THREE MINUTES WE
REALLY WANT TO GIVE A MINUTE AT
LEAST TO TÌM I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT THE OTHER P. FAST
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN PASSED. IS
REGARDING JUVENILE PRODUCTS AND
FOOD PACKAGING WHERE THERE IS.
OTHER POSSIBILITY OTHER
CHEMISTRY AVAILABLE AND THAT'S
NOT THE CASE HERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHEF BACK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ARE
COMMITTEE TEN CHESTER WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL-
GREAT TO SEE EVERYONE PERSON-
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS TODAY. WE
RECENTLY HAD A CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WITH THAT MR THINK
STAFF AND THE SPONSOR THE BILL
TO DISCUSS A FEW ISSUES- THAT WE
BELIEVE- NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AS
THIS BILL WOULD MOVE FORWARD. IS
INCLUDES A CONSISTENCY WITH
DEFINITIONS FROM A PREVIOUSLY
ENACTED LEGISLATION. ON THIS
TOPIC- CLARITY IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE PROPOSED EXEMPTIONS WERE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT- THAT WAS
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE- WE HAD
RAISED OUR PRIOR DISCUSSION AND
THE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR- AND
ARGUE SOME SUFFICIENT APPLIANCE
TIME. FOR A- ENTITIES AS IT WAS
MENTIONED THERE WAS A BILL TWO
BILLS PASSED LAST SESSION THAT
DEFINED REGULATED P. FOSS THIS
BILL PROPOSES A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT DEFINITION- THAT IN
OUR VIEW GREATLY INCREASES THE
PROBABILITY THAT EVEN PRODUCTS.
THAT MAY BE DESIGNED WITHOUT ANY
INTENSELY ADDED P. THOUGHTS.
COULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
PROHIBITION- ON THE COMPLIANCE
DATE OF PROVIDING JUST ONE YEAR
AFTER THE EFFECTIVE DATE- MAY
POSE A CHALLENGE FOR MATERIAL
SUPPLIERS- CONSUMER PRODUCT
COMPANIES TO REDESIGN PRODUCTS.
AND THEN FIND SUITABLE SUPPLIES
FOR ON A AS IT RELATES TO
ONGOING SUPPLY. CHAIN CHALLENGES
SO WE'RE INTERESTED IN AND
CONSTRUCTIVELY WORKING WITH THE
PROPONENTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANKS. ARM. JUST THINKING ABOUT
THE POINT SHE BROUGHT UP SO I
DON'T FORGET THEM OKAY- OTHERS
IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. A THANK YOU.
CRISTINA HILDEBRAND- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE VOICE BETRAYS
ADVOCACY I IN SUPPORT AND WE'RE
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF EDUCATE
ADVOCATE AND CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH. VERY
GOOD OTHERS IN THE ROOM WHO
MIGHT SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RYAN ELAINE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITE A
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
IDENTIFIED THE COMMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FORGET ARM
. NOW WE CAN GO TO THE PHONES-
MISTER OPERATOR AT ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN CHIANG CAN GIVE THEIR
NAME OUR POSITION AND-
ORGANIZATION. ANY PUT YOU WOULD
LIKE THAT SPEAKING LET ON THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO STAR OF ONE NUMBER
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JESSICA WAGNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THE NEXT A LITTLE ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE AIR. HOLDEN I
CAN I CAN SHARE MEMBERS PROPOSED
IT OFF CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL COUNT
FOR YOUR PRODUCT OR TO COUNSEL
POLICY POSITION NORTH AMERICA
AND WESTERN PLATTER WITH
MANAGEMENT PARTY AND OF COURSE
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE LINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD OKAY MEMBERS JUST MOVE ON
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAM SEES
LOBBYING COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
ABOUT ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS ARE
NOT YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IMPOSED BY
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU. THE
MOVE ON THE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GOOD TERRORISM BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ELAINE ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN AND ALSO WANT
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK CALPERS AND THE
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY L. A. AND- GO
THANK YOU. IT WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER WANTED TWENTY THANK YOU
TO MY UTILITY DISTRICT AND PART. THE NEXT TO GET A LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THINK CALLING IN SUPPORT IF THE
MEDICAL. EIGHTY SEVEN. AND WE'LL
GO TO WHENEVER NINETY FOUR HEAD
. HELLO QUINTINO BACK HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HELP
COPE WITH THE FACT THAT THE
PORTS. I WILL GO TO ONE NUMBER
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS DEAN TALLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. VERY GOOD SO THANK YOU
EVERYONE- DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER CHANG AYE AYE-
THIS REMINDED ME WHEN WE WERE IN
COLLEGE I AS TO SPRAY MY JEANS
THE SCOTCH GUARD AND WE'VE-
HOPEFULLY COME A LONG WAYS- I
DID AS WELL YEAH- I HAD A
QUESTION OF A FIRST TO THE AND
THE GENTLEMAN FROM ARNOLD AND
PORTER YOU INDICATED THAT THIS
WOULD BE A INDUSTRY KILLER AND
YOU HAVE TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. NUMEROUS LEADING
BRANDS THAT- THAT ARE EITHER ARE
HAVE FULLY PHASED OUT OR HAVE
COMMITTED THE FULL THE PHASING
OUT- HOW ARE WE TO- JUSTIFY.
THAT APPARENT CONTRADICTION YEAH
IT IT I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- SO THIS IS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF PRODUCT THAN THOSE THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT SORRY IT'S IS
DIFFICULT IT TOOK IT SHOULD
ANSWER- WHAT WE'RE TALKING WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT TODAY ARE
PRIMARILY OUTDOOR FURNITURE HI
TRAFFIC UPHOLSTERY- VOTING
COVERS- I THINK OF LIKE
AUTOMOBILE USES ON CONVERTIBLES
WHERE THAT MATERIAL MOVES BACK
SO THEY'RE ALL REALLY THE REALLY
DEMANDING. THERE'S A LOT OF
DEMANDING PERFORMANCE IS OFTEN
EXPOSED TO THE WEATHER TO THE
ELEMENTS AND IT'S EXPECTED TO
LAST- THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH
CLOTHING NECESSARILY SO IT'S
JUST A DIFFERENT KIND OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PRODUCTS OKAY
THANK- IT'S YOUR TEAM WITH THE
WIND WAS. DID IT DID I HEAR THAT
ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS WAS TO
EXCLUDE- RUGS. CARPETS. OKAY
YEAH I GUESS THAT WAS IT'S
BECAUSE THE- DEPARTMENT OF
TOXICS AND- S. SUBSTANTIVE
SUBSTANCE CONTROLS IS REVIEWING
THAT ALREADY OKAY THINGS ARE
ABOUT THE- AND MY LAST QUESTION
IS- ON ON PAGE NINE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. WE TALK
ABOUT THE- THE REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTIONS TAKING PLACE IN
TERMS OF- SOMETIMES EVEN WORSE
SHORT CHAIN NO NO YEAH IS IT-
HOW IS THIS BILL. IS THERE A
CONCERN THAT THIS BILL MAY LEAD
TO WORSE OUTCOMES. I KNOW WE
DON'T WE DON'T THINGS I THINK-
WE ARE CALLING FROM BELL GARDENS
KNOWS AND THIS IS HAPPENING I
MEAN ONE OF THE MAJOR REASONS
WE'RE DOING THIS IS BECAUSE OF
ALL THE WATER CONTAMINATION
THAT'S GOING AROUND THE STATE-
YOU WE HEARD THREE PREVIOUS
BILLS TALKING ABOUT WATER
CONTAMINATION- THAT IS ONE OF
THE- MAJOR OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN TERMS OF.
BANNING THESE TEXTILES AND SO BY
BY DOING SO I THINK WORK- WE'RE
WE'RE MOVING TOWARD THAT GOAL OF
HAVING CLEANER WATER ESPECIALLY
AT A TIME WHEN WE HAVE A DROUGHT
AND WE ARE VERY SCARCE WATER.
WELL NOTHING GOING TO DO IS
CONFIRM FURTHERCONTAMINATE OUR
ARMED OUR WATER STREAMS OUR
WATER SYSTEMS. I AM JUST TRYING
TO. I UNDERSTAND THAT I MEAN I
GET IT THAT WE- WANT TO. THERE
THERE THERE THERE IS TOO MUCH
TOO HIGH DETECTION OF P. FASTEN
OUR WATER SUPPLY AND YET. IF THE
ALTERNATIVES IMMINENT. POLICE
ACCORDING TO THIS ONE ARTICLE
SIDE IN THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
ALTURAS MAY EVEN BE WORSE THAN
THE P. FAST BEING REPLACED. HELP
ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF THE
NUMBER THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
YES PLEASE. SO THAT PART OF THE
REASON BUT A BILL ADDRESSING THE
FACT THAT THE CLASS OF THAT
CANNOT BE FROM- AND NEGATIVE YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOU COULD HAVE
GONE TO COLLEGE AND AFFODABLE
CHECK. OUT OF THE CLASS. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY ARE YOU FINISHED
WITH THE QUESTION US OKAY THEN
MS GARCIA. NO ACTUALLY I WAS
GONNA ANSWER BUT NOTHING ELSE.
OKAY BOB I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS-
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
AT MISTER CHAIR MISTER CHIANG
AND-  AGREE THE WATER IS REALLY
CRITICAL ILLNESS I THINK YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
SEVERAL WELLS IN MY DISTRICT AS
A RESULT IF YOU FAST
CONTAMINATION SO SOMETHING I'M-
INCREDIBLY AWARE OF AND
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF WORKING
TOWARDS I GUESS MIGHT HAVE A
COUPLE I'M CONCERNS WITH THE
BELL. THE FIRST I GUESS THE
SIMPLEST ONE WILL START WITH
WHICH IS- THE BILL FOCUSES ON
THE POINT OF SALE RIGHT WE'RE
BANNING THE POINT OF SALE APP
FOR THESE ITEMS AND I GUESS I
UNDERSTAND LARGE MANUFACTURERS
SERVICE STORES THAT THEY MAKE
THEIR OWN CLOTHING IF YOU WELL-
BUT- ATHLETES ARE IS NOW A VERY
POPULAR ITEM IN CALIFORNIA'S
BOUTIQUE SAYS THAT'S WHAT MOST
PEOPLE WHERE MOST OF THE TIME
POST CODE. SO I GUESS PART OF MY
CONCERN IS IF WE'RE TELLING
SELLERS NOT TO SELL IT BUT WE'RE
NOT DOING ANYTHING TO THOSE THAT
. MANUFACTURE AND DISTRIBUTE IT
HOW DO WE HOW DO THOSE SELLERS
NECESSARILY ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL
SELLERS NOTE WHETHER COMPLIANCE
OR NOT WITH THIS LAW. I DON'T.
YEAH I THINK I THINK IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION WHICH I THINK WE'RE
HAPPY TO EXPLORE THINK FOR US WE
HAD AS WE HAD TALKED YESTERDAY
PRIMARILY LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
LARGER COMPANIES- AND WE HADN'T-
HI THERE EXEMPTED SMALLER
SELLERS ARE LOOKED AT LABELING
BUT THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
COULD DEFINITELY TOUGHER LOOK AT
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SECONDS
CLEAR EDUCATION AND GUIDANCE I
UNDERSTAND ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE A MOM AND POP UP BOUTIQUE
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE TIME TO
DO ALL THIS RESEARCH ABOUT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEIR PRODUCTS OF.
WOULD BE HAPPIER OKAY FOR HOW TO
PROPERLY DRESSED UP THANK YOU AB
AND THEN MY SECOND QUESTION
WHICH IS LESS THAN WELL- IS SO.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I FEEL LIKE
THIS SCIENCE HAS BEEN CLEARLY
pHEARD YOUR WITNESS AND I
APOLOGIZE BUT I CAN'T REMEMBER
HER NAME FROM SPRING.
CALIBRATING FOR THE SPANISH
TALKING ABOUT SORT OF EXPOSURE
EVEN THROUGH THE WEARING OF
THESE CLOTHES THAT WAS THE FIRST
I HEARD OF THAT AS A POTENTIAL
POINT OF EXPOSURE- AND I'VE SEEN
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S
ANY SCIENCE IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
INDICATES THAT AS FAR AS I CAN
SEE. WHERE THAT IS BEEN
PRESENTED TO ME ALTHOUGH NO
SCIENCES BEEN PRESENTED TO ME AT
ALL ON THIS TOPIC WHICH- I WISH
WHAT HAPPENS ENERGY SEE- AND- SO
THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES OKAY
IS IT IS THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT ARE WE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WATER WAYS WHICH IS WHAT I HEAR
MR TEAM TALKING ABOUT. AND THEN
IT SEEMS LIKE VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD SCIENCE SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE ON WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS COMING OUT WASHING
MACHINES RIGHT AND I'VE YET TO
SEE THAT AND SO I THINK THAT
BANNING THE SALE OF. LARGE
CLASSES OF ATHLETIC WEAR
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT A
SMALL MOVE TO TAKE AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THE
SCIENCE TO BACK IT UP AND I FEEL
LIKE THE SIGNS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED IS WELL THEN OUR WATER
WHICH WE KNOW BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THERE'S MULTIPLE SOURCES OF
THIS. SO IS THIS THE SOURCE. IS
THIS A SOURCE CONCERN AND- I
JUST WANT THERE TO BE MORE
CLARITY FOR GONNA TAKE THE MOVE
TO BAN THE SALE OF THESE. THE
VAST PRODUCTS THAT THIS IS ON.
SO- THIS IS MY THIRD YEAR OF
KAREN P. FAST BILLS DARK DR
COURT TRADITIONALLY HAS.
REQUESTED OF VOLUMES ON
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH WHICH WE DID
PROVIDE HIM. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
GET THE NOTICE BUT WE ARE HAPPY
TO SHARE WITH YOU ALL THE
VARIETY OF SCIENTIFIC ARTICLES
BECAUSE I THINK THE RESEARCH IS
FAIRLY CLEAR- I DON'T KNOW IF
EITHER OF THE WITNESSES WANT TO
TALK ABOUT BOTH. THE WATER ISSUE
AS WELL AS DOCTOR IF DOCTOR
SCHNEIDER YOU WANT TO DIRECTLY
ADDRESS THE- NEAR THE CLOTHING
TOUCHING THE SKIN OR THE PRODUCT
THE TEXTILE TOUCHING THE SKIN
ISSUE. BUT HAPPY TO LET THE
EXPERTS KIND OF HANDLE THAT NE
BUT WOULD HAPPEN TO CATCH ALL
THE SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH IN IT.
SURE I'D BE HAPPY TO ADD ON IN
THE THAT'S REALLY GREAT QUESTION
THAT YOU ASK AND- I YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK IT'S- A MATTER OF
HUMAN DIRECT HUMAN EXPOSURE OR
VERSES. YOU CHEMICAL COMING UP
IN DRINKING WATER I THINK THESE
CONCERNED COVER BOTH- THIRD AT
TEN VERY LITTLE STUDY OF-
ABSORPTION THROUGH THE SKIN- OF
P. FAST CHEMICALS FROM PRODUCTS
SECTION. ARE TREATED WITH PEE
FAST- AND THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE HAS BEEN PRETTY MUCH
LIMITED TO ONE OR TWO CHEMICALS-
BUT IN ADDITION TO THE LARGE
POLYMERS THAT ARE PRESENT IN
PRODUCTS THERE ARE A NUMBER OF-
SMALLER CHEMICALS- THAT. TIME
ARE YOU STILL PROCESSING AIDS-
IN MAKING THE POLYMERS THAT MAY
ALSO BE PRESENT IN THE PRODUCT-
WE ALSO KNOW THAT PIZZA CAN BE.
VOLATILE LIES AS WELL- AND UP
AND IN DR SO THERE ARE NUMEROUS
WAYS THAT P. FAST IN PRODUCT.
CAN INCREASE EXPOSURES THROUGH
HOUSTON WEARING UP THE PRODUCT.
AS WELL AS THE BROADER LIFE
CYCLE CONCERNS AND THE.
POTENTIAL TO CONTAMINATE
DRINKING WATER. I CAN. QUICKLY
ADD THAT YOU KNOW THE IDEA HERE
IS TO BROADBAND UPON A CATEGORY
THAT THE BAND. HARMFUL CHEMICALS
AND UNDER LOTS OF PRODUCTS
ALREADY ON THE MARKET. I DON'T
USE THE CHEMICAL- AND- YOU KNOW
THOSE BECAUSE OF THE HARMS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CHEMICAL
BELIEVE. THAT THE- THAT I
JUSTIFIED EFFECTIVE. AND ALL
KIND OF VERY VALUABLE. TERMINAIS
SPEAKER THIS ISSUE VERY BRIEFLY
SURE. I WOULD AGREE THAT THE-
EXPOSURE STUDIES ARE PRIMARILY
LIMITED TO PFOA ANOTHER ACID NON
POLYMERIC P. FAST- AND I WOULD
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
PRODUCTS THAT I WAS DISCUSSING
TODAY ARE NOT. WASHED IN A
WASHING MACHINE- I DON'T KNOW
HOW THEY MAKE IT INTO A WATER
TABLE. PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE A POLYMER AND NOT GOING TO
GO AND NOT REALLY WATER SOLUBLE
SO I JUST DON'T THINK THOSE
CONCERNS BEING EXPRESSED OUR-
WOULD WOULD. THERE'S NO UTILITY
TO BANNING P. FAST IN THE
CATEGORY OF PRODUCTS AND
DISCOUNTS. SO FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T KNOW WHAT. THE FEST
PROBLEM AREAS AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT AND I
WILL GO THROUGH THAT. BOB DID
YOUR DO YOUR EXPERTS HAVE A
COMMENT ON P. FAST POLYMERS. A
LOT OFTEN TWO OTHER MISTER CAR.
TO CAR DOCTOR SCHNEIDER HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT. ON THE P. FAST
POLITICIANS START UP. YES I'M
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT PART
SECOND NINE BY DOCTOR SHAPESHIFT
THAT FIRE TO FOLLOW UP- THE
FIRST THING I'LL SAY IS THAT THE
TV AT THE DEPARTMENT TALKING
CONTROL I LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE
AND REGULATE IT HALF OF THE
CLASS AND THEY SAY THAT ALL
THOSE NEED TO BE AT THAT AGE.
WHICH ARE EITHER THE BUILDING
BLOCKS OF THAT OR THE-
DEGRADATION PRODUCTS OF ALL
THESE THAT THEY PUTTING POLITICS
AND THEREFORE THAT NEEDS-
MATERIAL AND UP- IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND IN OUR BODY. AND
THAT EVEN DIE FOR THE LIFE CYCLE
OF COLIN WAS NOT AS BIG AS THEY
BEGIN MONDAY AND UP IN- IN.
LANDFILL OF THE COMMISSION TO
WATER TABLES AND ONE CLOTHING AS
MUCH MAKE IT END UP IN THE WATER
TABLE THAT WAY AS WELL FINALLY I
ALSO WANTED. TO JUST FLAG THAT-
IT DOES NOT COME ITEM AND BY THE
TERRY. THE LITTLE FOR EARLIER
THE CAN. NO COVERED TECH. NO HOW
TO GOOD AND- YEAH. IS SO BOTTOM
LINE EVAN ABILITY TO CARE. OUT.
BOB SO THERE SHOULD THEY HAVE
THE SAME ISSUE. I'M GOING TO ASK
MY- FELLOW TO LOOK INTO THIS.
AND ILL GET AN ANSWER FOR YOU-
BEFORE- IT. THE QUESTION IS DO
WE LET IT OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY OR DO YOU WANT TO WAIT.
FOR MY NECK CHAIR I DON'T THE
INTERNET MY OWN VOTE. IN THE- I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS I
DO WANT MY- SIZE FELLOW TO TAKE
A LOOK INTO IT. SO THAT WE HAVE
A BETTER IDEA SINCE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS JUST BROUGHT
UP HERE. I DO YOU KNOW IF THERE
IS A PROBLEM WITH THE FAST AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND I INSISTED
ON THAT BEFORE I ALLOWED THE
BILL TO COME TO US AND IN
PARTICULAR STUDY BY THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION DIRECTORATE GENERAL-
FOUND THAT- IN FACT THESE
TEXTILE. PRODUCTS CONTAINING P.
FAST- DO YOU IN FACT CONTRIBUTE
TO EMISSIONS OF P. FAST AS WELL
AS CONTAMINATION OF SOIL AND
DRINKING WATER I MEAN THAT'S
DEFINITE- AND ACCORDING TO. THE
DEPARTMENT OF- INCLUDING INFANTS
YOUNG CHILDREN AND PEOPLE OF
CHILD BEARING AGE. ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE PASSED FROM LEFT LEATHER
AND TEXTILE FURNISHINGS. AND IT
FURTHER THE STUDY STATED P.
FASHION TEXTILES CAN BE RELEASED
INTO INDOOR AIR. HUMILIATING
DUST AND YOUR EXPOSURE TO P.
FASTER HERS WHEN PEOPLE INHALE
AND INGEST THIS CONTAMINATED AIR
AND DUST SO. I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'S A REASON TO. EXCLUDE OUR
FURNITURE. IS WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO FIVE. AGAIN WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK WORK I'M WILLING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ANY EVIDENCE YOU HAVE.
HASN'T COME UP TILL NOW- I WOULD
LIKE TO GET THE BILL OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE UNLESS THERE'S PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO KEEP IT IN THE
COMMITTEE. UNTIL LOVE WE HAVE
OUR NEXT HEARING BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO GET IT OUT NOW AND IN
THE MEANTIME WE CAN LOOK AT
THESE ISSUES. AND I CAN WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THOSE SO. THE
AUTHORS OKAY IN THE OPPOSITION
IS OKAY. I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL OUT TODAY. WE STILL WITH
MORE QUESTIONS. BUT I DO FOR
THAT WE OUGHT TO GIVE A FAIR.
HEARING TO WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY
AND- I HAVE SOMEBODY HERE WHO'S
NOT AN EXPERT BUT HE HAS ALL THE
BACKGROUND TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND- WILL BE GLAD
TO LOOK AT ANY PAPERS AND SUCH
THAT YOU HAVE SO WE WILL LOOK AT
THAT IN GREATER DETAIL. ALL
RIGHT MISS GARCIA JUST AS DOES
THIS THE DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE TO
SWANA CONTINUED AS TO. KEEP OUR
P. FIVE AS A CLASS AND NOT START
TO PUSH HIM OUT AS WE HAVE SEEN
THE SHORT CHAIN BEHAVE VERY
SIMILARLY TO THE LAUNCHINGS
LAUNCHING SO SHE BREAKDOWN A
LOOK LIKE THE CHARGING ALONG THE
WAY AND SO AS WE ARE DOING THIS
WORK I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY
WASHING THIS FURNITURE OR- IN
IN. THE LAUNDRY BUT THEY ARE
ENDING UP IN OUR LANDFILLS AND
THAT LAND FILLED AND IT- THE
MATERIALS LEACHING INTO OUR
WATER SYSTEM THAT WINTER GROUND
THAT WAY AS WONDERS A LOT OF
SCIENCE- ON THAT- AS WELL OUT
THERE AND SO. I'M GONNA GO READ
ABOUT PEOPLE'S POLYMERS. THANK
YOU FOR ADDING TO. TO MY
HOMEWORK AND IN THE SPACE BUT I
JUST AS THE NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE AND I KNOW THE OTHER
WORKS WITH THE OPPOSITION TO TRY
TO FIND COMMON GROUND AS
POSSIBLE I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE KEEP ASSESSED. AT
DIFFERENTIATE. ALONG THE WAY I
ALSO HAVE A BUDGET LETTER ON
HELPING MUNICIPALITIES AND SMALL
WATER AGENCIES PAY FOR THIS.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME TALK TO
MY OFFICE A LOT. OKAY ANYTHING
ELSE SO I JUST I AM YOU KNOW I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS I THINK I'M GOING
TO HOLD OFF UNTIL I GET. BETTER
ANSWERS TO MY QUESTIONS BUT
RESPECT THE CHAIRS FOR AND I
THINK IT WILL VOTE TODAY AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING. ALL
RIGHT- DR RANDALL IS BACK. I'M
SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM-
MISSPELLED K. HAND SHE'S GOING
TO HOLD OFF TILL NOW SHE SHE
LOOKS AT THE SCIENCE LITTLE
BETTER SIR ANYONE ELSE WHO FEELS
THAT THEY NEED MORE TIME ON THIS
IF NOT THEN WE HAVE THE VOTES TO
GET IT OUT. I'LL GET IT OUT.
VERY GOOD- LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE
A MOTION YET. THIS AND SALAS
BROUGH WANTS TO SECOND ALL RIGHT
MISTER MURATSUCHI ALL RIGHT-
MADAM SECRETARY. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
TANG THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR. CORK BY
CORK HI SMITH. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
I OUR QUE HAN OUR CANNOT VOTING
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I MATHIS WHAT A
TO G. MORE TWO GI WALDRON. WE
HAVE FIVE VOTES I HAVE ENOUGH TO
MAKE YOU VERY MUCH YOUR WELL I
AM I AM WORLD NOW DO ADD ONS AND
I GUESS- OUR QUE HAN WAS HERE
FOR THE WHOLE THING SO I WAS
ASKED- BECAUSE THERE WAS A
PORTION IN TIME WHERE THE VOTE
FOR ITEM SIX AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN WAS NOT RECORDED- WE
HAD A GLITCH IN THE SOUND I NEED
TO RE READ- AS WITH AS MANY
REMEMBERS HER AS POSSIBLE. THE
VOTE SO IS AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN ROBERT RIVAS THE MOTION
WAS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS-
MOTIONING AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA SECONDING QUIRK
VOTED ON BY SMITH VOTED I'D-
POWER QUE HAN VOTED AYE CRISTINA
GARCIA VOTED AYE HOLDEN VOTED
AYE MATHIS VOTED AYE. AND WHAT A
TO G. VOTED ON WHICH AREBROUGHT
THE. VOTE COUNT TO SEVEN ZERO AT
THAT POINT. I WANT TO GET UP FOR
THE- ALL RIGHT. YEAH SO WHY
DON'T YOU START WITH THE ADD ON
STARTING WITH- CONSENT CALENDAR
AND GOING FROM THERE OKAY SO NOW
WE CAN. THIS IS A TO ADD ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE VOTE
STANDS AT SIX ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I HOLDEN HOLDEN I
WALDRON WALDRON I THAT'S. NINE
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO ITEM ONE. I
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
SMITH. ITEM TWO AB TWENTY FIFTY
NINE CARILLO. THE VOTE IS AT
FIVE ONE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'M
SORRY ARAMBULA I HOLDEN HOLDEN I
WALDRON WALDRON I. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY THREE
BLANCA RUBIO. THE VOTE IS AT
FIVE ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I WALDRON. WALDRON
I. ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS AB TWENTY
ONE OH SIX ROBERT RIVAS. THE
VOTE SETS AT SIX ONE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO. THE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWENTY ONE OH EIGHT
ROBERT RIVAS. THE VOTE IS POINT ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I WALDRON. WALDRON NO.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN ROBERT RIVAS THE VOTE
IS SEVEN ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE WALDRON. WALDRON I. FOR ITEM
SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
CORK. THE VOTERS AT SIX ZERO
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I HOLDEN
HOLDEN I WALDRON WALDRON I
BRAINERD SO WE'VE FROM UNLESS
THE REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT THINKS
THAT MR MATHESON MR NOW THEY'RE
NOT COMING BACK THEN WE HAVE
EVERYBODY ON RECORD WHO WANTS TO
BE ON RECORD AND I'M CALLING
THE- COMMITTEE HEARING IT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF- PARTICIPATION WE HAD
TODAY- AND THEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE LIKE. GREAT FRIENDS
. IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU WITH THE
BEST GUY NO I'M STILL WEARING
ONE BUT- YOU KNOW WE ALL LOOK
FRIENDLIER WE DON'T HAVE TO WEAR
THEM. THANK YOU EVERYONE THANK
YOU. BUDGET YEAH DIFFICULT. GOOD
MORNING. HOWEVER ONE OF THE YEAH. REVIEW OF THE EVERYTHING
DESCRIPTION OF THE PART YEAH
OKAY. YEAH SURE. FORTY THREE NOT
AND IF YOU- AND IT BRINGS. ALL
RIGHT. YES TRANSPARENT YEAH. THE
NEW YORKER FOR A LACK OF OKAY
YEAH I THINK LIKE YOU KNOW
WONDERFUL.
YEAH I THINK EVERYTHING I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO GO TO WORK
. I THINKING ABOUT THAT ONE
THING. THANK YOU KNOW AND.
ELEVEN EARLY ME THINK YOU HAVE A
GREAT DIFFERENT KIND THING WHERE
YOU GO. RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR A
JOB. YEAH. AND PROBABLY HAVE.
METAGAME. WELCOME BUT THAT WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE AND LIKE THE OF
THE- PEOPLE WHO LIVE WITH. TO
THE YEAH. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR YOU
SOME OF THE LIKE WHENEVER.